ओके ओके सो नाउ वी आर लाइव हियर आई थिंक
अब सही है। एक्चुअली मैंने लाइव
स्ट्रीमिंग अ सॉफ्टवेयर से स्टार्ट कर
दिया था। बट यहां लाइव स्टार्ट करना मैं
भूल गया था। सो यहां लाइव स्टार्ट नहीं
थी। इस वजह से आपको
मैं विज़िबल नहीं हो पा रहा होगा। अभी आई
थिंक विजिबिलिटी आ गई होगी पूरी।
अभी विजिबिलिटी आ गई होगी। राइट?
गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग। नमस्ते। नमस्ते
टू ऑल। नमस्ते टू ऑल।
ओके। सो आई होप आप सभी अच्छे होंगे। एंड
अभी जो है आप मुझे एक बार बता दीजिए।
ऑडियो वीडियो सब कुछ क्लियर है। एक बार
प्लीज बता दीजिए मुझे। सभी लोग बता दीजिए।
ऑडियो वीडियो एवरीथिंग इज़ क्लियर। प्लीज
लेट मी नो गाइस। बिकॉज़ वी आर गोइंग टू
स्टार्ट ऑन अमेजिंग टॉपिक ऑफ़ आवर एसओसी।
एंड एक और चीज मैं आपको बताना चाहता हूं
कि अब से आपकी एसओसी की जो क्लासेस हैं
थोड़ी फ्रीक्वेंटली होंगी। थोड़ी
जल्दी-जल्दी आया करेंगी। टारगेट तो मैंने
दे रखा है कि हर क्लास के वीडियो पे 200
कमेंट्स का। बट मुझे नहीं लगता कि 200 लोग
भी सिंसियर हैं बहुत ज्यादा इस ट्रेनिंग
को लेकर। मुझे लगता है अराउंड 100 पीपल आर
सिंसियर अ फॉर दिस पर्टिकुलर ट्रेनिंग। तो
मैं उसी को कंसीडर करके चलूंगा। एंड
क्योंकि मुझे तो ट्रेनिंग करानी है। मुझे
तो ट्रेनिंग कंप्लीट करनी है। जब मैंने
आपसे प्रॉमिस करा हुआ है तो आई विल बी
डिलीवरिंग दैट पर्टिकुलर थिंग। उस प्रॉमिस
को मैं नहीं तोडूंगा। मैं उसको
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] डिलीवर तो
करूंगा। तो मैं आपके भरोसे अगर डिलीवर
करूंगा तो यह ट्रेनिंग 6 महीने से भी
ज्यादा चलेगी। एंड 6 महीने में भी नहीं
खत्म होगी। आपके अगर मैं भरोसे रहा तो तो
इससे मुझे यह पता चल गया है कि आप लोग
भरोसे के लायक नहीं है। बस क्लियर कट बात
है। यह आपको शायद जो भी आपको जैसा भी लगे
आई डोंट केयर। बट आप लोग भरोसे के लायक
बिल्कुल भी नहीं है और आप लोग मेरी बात
नहीं मानते हैं। मतलब मैं मेरे को यह भी
आईडिया लग चुका है कि आप लोग मेरी बात
समझते नहीं है। ना ही उस बात को फॉलो करते
हो। ना ही उससे कोई आपको मतलब होता है।
क्योंकि आपको लगता है कि फ्री में मिल ही
रहा है सब कुछ। इनको तो लाना ही है।
इन्होंने बोला है लाने को तो लाएंगे ही
लाएंगे। नहीं तो इनकी रेपुटेशन पे बात आ
जाएगा। तो क्या ही करें यार। छोड़ो ना कौन
सा कमेंट करना है, क्या ही करना है। यह
आपने टेक इन फॉर ग्रांटेड लेके बहुत लोगों
ने यह चीज कर ली है। बट ठीक है। इट्स ओके।
चलेगा। कोई दिक्कत नहीं है। स्टिल आई एम
एज अ ट्रेनर, एज अ टीचर मेरा जो फर्ज बनता
है मैं आपको वह डिलीवर करूंगा। एंड बाकी
आपकी मर्जी है। अगर आप 200 कमेंट्स कर
देते हैं इट्स गुड एंड काफी इनकरेजिंग
लगेगा। नहीं भी करते हैं स्टिल जो है 100
कमेंट्स के बाद भी वीडियोस मैं ला दिया
करूंगा। जैसे 100 कमेंट्स होंगे जेन्युइन
कमेंट्स। वो फर्जी वाले कमेंट्स होंगे तो
ऑब्वियस सी बात है वो एप्लीकेबल नहीं
होगा। 100 जेन्युइन कमेंट्स भी होंगे। अब
अब इतना भी अगर आप नहीं कर पाओगे 100
मैंने 250 पहले रखा था कमेंट का टारगेट।
फिर 200 किया आपके कहने पे। फिर अब मैं
डायरेक्ट 50% डिस्काउंट करके यहां पे
कमेंट्स में भी डिस्काउंट हो रहे हैं।
बताओ सर यहां पे 100 कमेंट्स पे मैं अब आ
चुका हूं। ठीक है? अब यहां 100 कमेंट्स भी
अगर आपका नहीं हो पाता है तो आपकी ही गलती
है। ये साइबर जैन जो बोल रहे हैं सर हमारी
क्या गलती है? ये गलती आपकी ही है। अगर आप
100 कमेंट्स भी नहीं कर पा रहे हैं। कुछ
लोगों ने मैसेज किया था कि सर इतनी गैप
देंगे तो फिर कैसे होगा? हम हम तो कर रहे
हैं। हमारी क्या गलती है सर? ऐसे कैसे
चलेगा? तो गलती आपकी ही है गाइस। जो लोग
भी इसके पार्ट हैं इस पूरे ट्रेनिंग के
उनकी ही गलती है। मैं लिटरली बता रहा हूं।
अब कमेंट करवाना ये मेरे बेनिफिट का कोई
चीज नहीं था। कमेंट करवाना मेरे बेनिफिट
का चीज नहीं था। बेनिफिट का क्या चीज था?
शेयर करवाना कि लोगों को शेयर मैं करवाऊं।
राइट? ये मेरे लिए बेनिफिशियल होता।
क्योंकि कमेंट तो कोई भी आ के 10 20 कमेंट
कर देगा हो जाएगा। मेरा उसमें क्या
बेनिफिट है? कोई बेनिफिट नहीं था। बेनिफिट
मेरा तब होता जब मैं बोलता आपको कि शेयर
करो, स्क्रीनशॉट भेजो। 10 लोगों को शेयर
करो तब जाके व्यूज का बेनिफिट मिलता है
मुझे। राइट? बट यहां पे कमेंट इसलिए मैं
बोलता था ताकि आप उस कमेंट के बहाने इस
पर्टिकुलर वीडियो से इंगेज हो जाओ। मजबूरी
में भी वीडियो को ओपन करो, कमेंट करो। इसी
बहाने कहीं थोड़ा देख लो, थोड़ा सीख लो।
तो ये आपके लिए था। बट आपके बस की बात है
नहीं ये। मैं अपना कंटिन्यू करता हूं। 100
कमेंट्स कर देता हूं। 100 कमेंट्स आप
कीजिए। एंड दैट्स इट।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ठीक है? उसके
अलावा आई डोंट नो एनीथिंग। अगर आप वो भी
100 कमेंट नहीं कर पा रहे हैं तो इट्स
टोटली अप टू यू। यू आर रिस्पांसिबल ईच एंड
एवरीवन जो यहां पे देखते हैं। मैं आपको
लिटरली आपको लग रहा होगा कि मैं आपको
स्कॉल्ड कर रहा हूं, डांट रहा हूं। बट मैं
ऐसे ही बात करता हूं। इसको आप दिल पे मत
ले लेना। बट आई टॉक इन द सेम वे जो मुझे
पहले जानते हैं। वो मुझे अच्छे से जानते
होंगे। सिमिलर वे आई टॉक टू एवरीबॉडी कि
मैं कोई भी चीज ऑथेंटिकेट वे में बात करता
हूं। जब हम कोई चीज ऑथेंटिसिटी के साथ
प्रोवाइड कर रहे हैं, ठोक बजा के प्रोवाइड
कर रहे हैं। जॉब रेडी तक की क्वालिटी दे
रहे हैं। कोई पैसा चार्ज नहीं कर रहे हैं।
आपसे तो पैसा नहीं ले रहे हैं ना। कोई
पैसा नहीं ले रहे हैं। YouTube हमें पैसा
दे, Google दे। उससे आपको क्या मतलब है?
हम आपको फ्री में दे रहे हैं। सिंपल सा
फंडा है और वो भी क्वालिटी के साथ। तो
आपका इतना फर्ज अगर नहीं बन रहा है या आप
नहीं कर पा रहे हैं तो इट्स टोटली जो
व्यूअर्स हैं उनकी फॉल्ट है। मैं ऐसा
मानता हूं। बाकी आपकी मर्जी है। आप अगर
अपनी फॉल्ट नहीं मानते हैं दैट्स ओके।
टोटली फाइन। मैं उसको उस पे जबरदस्ती आपके
लिए कुछ नहीं बोल रहा। ठीक है? चलिए अब
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यहां पे आज जो सेशन है और आज के बाद के
सेशंस थोड़ी फ्रीक्वेंट आएंगे। मैंने पहले
ही बोला कि 100 कमेंट्स अब कर दिए हैं। अब
ये तो तुरंत आप कर करवा सकते हैं। मुझे
पता है एक से दो दिन में काफी है। हो
जाएगा क्योंकि मुझे भी ट्रेनिंग को
कंप्लीट करनी है। मुझे भी वो चीज कंप्लीट
करके एंड आपको एक लेवल पे लेकर जाना है।
तो चलिए बिफोर वी स्टार्ट मैं पहले ही
बोलता हूं हमेशा से बोलता हूं कि इस चैनल
को जब आप ओपन करेंगे लाइव सेक्शन में जब
आप आएंगे तो एसओसी की कोई सी भी क्लास की
वीडियो को ओपन कर लीजिएगा। सबसे पहला काम
आपको करना है।
इसको ओपन कर ओपन करके यहां डिस्क्रिप्शन
में जाइएगा। दो लिंक्स आपको मिलते हैं। एक
WhatsApp ग्रुप का मिलेगा, एक WhatsApp
चैनल का मिलेगा। बस पहला काम यह है आपका
कि WhatsApp ग्रुप को ज्वाइन जरूर कर
लीजिएगा। ये एसओसी का स्पेशल ग्रुप है
जहां सारे नोटिफिकेशन, रिसोर्सेज जो भी
अपडेट्स हैं आपको यहां पे एसओसी की आएंगी।
ये है WhatsApp चैनल डिफ्रॉनिक्स aडमी
सर्च भी कर सकते हैं चैनल पे WhatsApp
चैनल पे। यहां पे आपको ओवरऑल कंप्लीट
जोेंस एंड जो नोटिफिकेशन वगैरह आती है वो
सबसे पहले आती है। इसके बाद ये Lindin पेज
Lindin प्रोफाइल है। आप यहां पे आके मुझसे
कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं या मेरी काम को फॉलो
कर सकते हैं। व्हाटएवर आप जिस तरीके से
चाहे कर सकते हैं। और Lindin पे ही आप
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स सर्च करेंगे तो आपको हमारी
कंपनी का Lindin पेज मिल जाएगा। इस कंपनी
के पेज को फॉलो करके आप हमारी स्टार्टअप
हमारी कंपनी के जर्नी को फॉलो कर सकते
हैं। हम जब रेगुलर टाइम टू टाइम कुछ यहां
पोस्ट करेंगे कुछ चीजें आपको बताएंगे तो
आपको यहां के थ्रू ही पता चल जाएगी। तो ये
पेज है। इसको आप फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। यहां पे
लगभगलगभग 22,000 लोग हमसे जुड़े हुए हैं।
हमारे साथ जुड़े हुए हैं। एंड आप भी इसका
पार्ट बन सकते हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यह हमारा है एक्स का पेज यानी कि Twitter
पेज डिफ्रानिस एकडमी। यह हमारा है डिफरानी
एकडमी Instagram पेज। आप इसको फॉलो कर
सकते हैं। ये Instagram का मेरा पर्सनल
पेज है। लाइक मेरा खुद का पर्सनल एक पेज
है जहां पे मैं खुद इसको यूज़ करता हूं,
हैंडल करता हूं। एंड आई पोस्ट माय रेगुलर
थिंग्स एंड अपडेट्स एंड ऑल। तो आप चाहे तो
आप यहां पे भी आके फॉलो कर सकते हैं मुझे।
साथ ही [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ये
वेबसाइट है। वेबसाइट पे आके आप हमारी जो
भी वेबसाइट है उसको एक्सप्लोर करके एकडमी
पे जाके हमारे कोर्सर्सेस को एक्सप्लोर कर
सकते हैं बाय डिफ्रॉनिक्स एंड ये नंबर पे
कांटेक्ट करके आप हमसे किसी भी तरह का
क्वेरी कोई भी क्वेश्चन आप हमसे कर सकते
हैं। कोई भी तरह का कोई क्वेरी हो कुछ भी
हो एनीथिंग ऑन WhatsApp। राइट? सो दैट्स
ऑल फॉर दिस पर्टिकुलर थिंग। एंड वीडियोस
जब भी आप देखते हैं तो वीडियोस जब आप देख
लेते हैं तो चैनल को अगर सब्सक्राइब नहीं
करके रखा होगा तो सब्सक्राइब करके बेल
आइकॉन प्रेस कर दीजिएगा। यह ऑल कर
दीजिएगा। साथ ही में हर वीडियो के नीचे एक
हाइप का ऑप्शन होता है। हाइप के ऑप्शन पे
क्लिक करते हैं तो YouTube उन वीडियोस को
ज्यादा रिकमेंड करता है अगर आप हाइप करते
हैं वीडियोस को तो। दैट्स ऑल फॉर यू गाइस।
अब हम स्टार्ट करते हैं आज के सेशन को। आज
का जो सेशन है ये बहुत ही इंटरेस्टिंग
सेशन होने वाला है। क्योंकि एक एक
कॉम्प्लेक्स टॉपिक को मैंने बहुत इजी वे
में आपको समझाने की कोशिश की है आज। एंड
इस टॉपिक को अगर आप समझ गए हैं तो
नेटवर्किंग का मेजर जो पार्ट है आपके हाथ
में होगा। तो सिंपल सा फंडा है। आज हम
करने वाले हैं। आईपी एड्रेसिंग के बारे
में जानने वाले हैं। सबनेटिंग के बारे में
जानने वाले हैं। सीआईडीआर के बारे में
जानने वाले हैं। एआरपी के बारे में जानने
वाले हैं। मैक एड्रेस के बारे में जानने
वाले हैं। ओवरऑल हम शानदार टॉपिक्स को डील
करने वाले हैं। अब यहां पे नेटवर्किंग का
जो पार्ट है गाइस, ठीक है? एसओसी में
नेटवर्किंग का पार्ट उसमें जितने भी
टॉपिक्स हैं उनमें आधे टॉपिक्स हो चुके
हैं हमारे। कुछ टॉपिक्स जो बचे हैं वो भी
जल्दी ही कंप्लीट हो जाएंगे। इसके बाद हम
ओएस एंड कुछ और जो हमारे कांसेप्ट्स हैं
उस पे जाके उसको खत्म करेंगे। एंड देन हम
आ जाएंगे एसओसी की हमारी एक्चुअल जो हमारी
चीजें हैं जो लॉग्स हो गई एंड लॉग्स का
मैनेजमेंट हो गया एसआईएम हो गए और सारी
मतलब अलर्ट्स के अलर्ट्स को कैसे किस
तरीके से आप एग्जामिन करेंगे किस तरीके से
आप आगे रिसोंड उसको फॉरवर्ड करेंगे या खुद
रिॉल्व करेंगे किस तरीके से अटैक को समझ
समझेंगे पहचानेंगे लाइक रिकॉग्नाइज करेंगे
हर एक चीज जो एक एल1 के लिए जरूरी होती हम
उसके बाद उस पे आ जाएंगे एंड वहां से आपकी
प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन स्टार्ट हो
जाएगी। मतलब जो प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट है वो
ऑलमोस्ट स्टार्ट हो जाएगा जो कि हम
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन के थ्रू, लैब्स के थ्रू एंड
वॉक थ्रूस के थ्रू ये सारी चीजों के थ्रू
हम लेके चलेंगे समझेंगे ताकि जब आप रियल
वर्ल्ड में ऐसी टूल्स पे काम करेंगे एसओसी
एल1 के लिए जब जॉब के लिए जाएंगे एंड जब
इन टूल्स को यूज़ करना शुरू करेंगे तो आपको
ऑलरेडी सारी चीजें आती रहेंगी एल1
प्रोफाइल के एंड आप एक जॉब रेडी एसोसिएट
वन बन गए रहेंगे। जो लोग फाइनल ईयर, थर्ड
ईयर, फाइनल ईयर, प्रीफाइनल ईयर में हैं वो
लोग भी टेंशन मत लीजिए। अभी आपके पास पूरा
टाइम है। इतना टेंशन नहीं लेना है। वैसे
भी अगर आप नहीं भी कर रहे होते हैं ये तो
अगर आपकी कॉलेज से प्लेसमेंट नहीं होती
है, तो उसके बाद भी 3-4 महीने भागदौड़
करनी ही पड़ती है। एंड तब जाके कई लोगों
की प्लेसमेंट्स होती है। तो आपके पास एक
टाइमलाइन है अभी भी। आपको हार नहीं मानी
है। कंटिन्यू कीजिए। बस दैट्स इट।
एक्सप्लोर करना भी सीखिए। एक्सप्लोर भी
करते रहिए। अब यहां पे आते हैं
सबसे [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] पहले हे
गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग नमस्ते नमस्ते
कुड यू प्लीज कवर द फॉलोइंग टॉपिक्स
रिक्वायर्ड फॉर एसोस एल वन रोल लाइन
बेसिक्स फायर वॉल बेसिक्स बैच
स्क्रिप्टिंग क्राउड स्ट्राइक वायरस टोटल
वायरस सब कवर होगी भाई बिल्कुल बेफिक्र
रहिए सुzoए जो जोज चीजें आपकी एल1 के लिए
रिक्वायरमेंट है जितनी रिक्वायरमेंट है वो
मैं सब करूंगा एक जॉब रेडी प्रोफाइल के
लिए दैट्स इट चलिए सबसे पहले समझते हैं
व्हाट इज एन IPपी एड्रेस देखो IP एड्रेस
के बारे आप सब जानते हैं कि IP एड्रेस
क्या होता है? एक चार ऑक्टेट का एक नंबर
होता है। जैसे कि मान लो 192.168.2.1
एक हो गया 10.1.1.2
ऐसे करके IP होती है। तो ये आपको पता है
IP एड्रेस क्या होता है? बट यहां पे
दिक्कत क्या है कि मुझे इसका कांसेप्ट
समझना है। अब एंड यहां एक डेफिनेशन लिखा
हुआ है क्या? एन आईपी एड्रेस इज़ अ यूनिक
आइडेंटिफायर फॉर अ डिवाइस ऑन अ नेटवर्क।
एक यूनिक आइडेंटिफायर है किसी भी डिवाइस
का एक नेटवर्क के ऊपर में। अब यहां पे
कहने का मतलब क्या है कि नेटवर्क में
मल्टीपल डिवाइसेस होते हैं। अब हर डिवाइस
को पहचानना तो जरूरी है कि भैया ये कौन सा
डिवाइस है वो कौन सा डिवाइस है। राइट? अब
एक एरिया में एक सिटी में या एक छोटे से
यू कैन से कि वार्ड में वार्ड बोल लो या
मोहल्ले मोहल्ले का मोहल्ले में कई घर
होते हैं। राइट? बहुत सारे घर होते हैं।
अब एक कोई पोस्टमैन आता है चिट्ठी लेकर
डाकिया डाक लेकर आता है तो वो किसके घर
डिलीवर करेगा? ये कैसे पता चलता है उसको?
एड्रेस से पता चलता है। सिमिलर वे
कंप्यूटरटर्स
सर्वर्स बहुत सारी डिवाइसेस होते हैं
नेटवर्क के अंदर में। ठीक है? नेट एक
नेटवर्क में कंप्यूटरटर्स हैं, लैपटॉप
मतलब लैपटॉप्स हैं, पीसीस हैं, मोबाइल
फोंस हैं, राउटर्स हैं, स्विचेस है, अदर
डिवाइसेस हैं। देयर आर मल्टीपल डिवाइसेस
जो एक नेटवर्क में काम कर रहे होते हैं।
अब उनको कौन पहचानेगा? कैसे पहचानेंगे? तो
उसको पहचाना जाता है IP एड्रेस से। यानी
कि एक ऐसा एड्रेस जो उस पर्टिकुलर डिवाइस
का होता है एक यूनिक आइडेंटिफायर उस
डिवाइस को यूनिकली आइडेंटिफाई किया जा
सकता है। अब देखो अब आपके घर के एड्रेस पे
आपका जो घर का एड्रेस है वही एड्रेस किसी
और का तो नहीं हो सकता अंटिल एंड अनलेस कि
वो आप ही के घर में ऊपर के फ्लोर पे या
किसी और फ्लोर पे रहता हो उसमें भी उसको
लिखना पड़ेगा। फर्स्ट फ्लोर, सेकंड फ्लोर,
थर्ड फ्लोर, ग्राउंड फ्लोर, टॉप फ्लोर
क्या है वो लिखना पड़ेगा। तभी जाके समझ
में आ जाएगा। तो उसी तरीके से हर डिवाइस
का एक यूनिक आइडेंटिफायर होता है नेटवर्क
के अंदर में। उसको हम IPपी एड्रेस बोलते
हैं। यानी कि आपका फोन है उसका एक IP
एड्रेस होगा। आपका एक लैपटॉप है उसको भी
उसको भी एक IPपी एड्रेस मिली होगी। आपका
एक पीसी है एक उसी नेटवर्क में उसको भी एक
IPपी एड्रेस मिली होगी। इसी में एक राउटर
है उसको भी एक IPपी एड्रेस मिली होगी। तो
हर डिवाइस को एक IP एड्रेस मिली होती है
और वो IP एड्रेस जनरली नॉर्मली अगर हम
हैकिंग को साइड में कर दें अभी के लिए
विदाउट छेड़छाड़ एक यूनिक नंबर होता है।
यूनिक आइडेंटिफायर होता है। राइट?
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़][गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
चलिए इतना समझ में आ गया होगा। एग्जांपल
ऑफ़ IPपी एड्रेस इज़ सिंपल 192 168.10 और
बहुत सारी ऐसे होती हैं। आगे हम और भी
देखेंगे कि क्या-क्या होती है। ओके? अब
यहां पे आते हैं। IP का मतलब यहां पे क्या
होता है? डिवाइस की आइडेंटिटी प्लस
लोकेशन। बस ये मतलब होता है। IP का मतलब
इंटरनेट प्रोटोकॉल, एड्रेस का मतलब
एड्रेस। तो डिवाइस की आइडेंटिफिकेशन
और लोकेशन
उसकी नेटवर्क में ये डिनोट करता है आईपी।
बस यही हमारी IP होती है। अब IP में भी
कुछ चक्कर है। IP क्या होते हैं? 32 बिट्स
के होते हैं। चार ऑक्टेट में। अब ये क्या
मतलब हुआ 32 बिट्स का? चार ऑक्टेट। व्हाट
इज दिस? इसको हम समझते हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
देखो
अब मान लो एक IP है मान लो
92 16
192 1681
ये आईपी
ठीक है [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] डर डरो
मत यार मेहनत डरो मत टेंशन मत लो ठीक है
डरो मत मस्त मस्ती में रहो
कोई बात नहीं कुलदीप सीएसके का मैच का
हाईलाइट देख लेना। ठीक है? सो यहां पे 192
168.1.1
अब यहां पे ये IP है। तो इस IP का ये
मैंने आपको अभी थोड़ी देर पहले बोला था ना
कि 32 बिट्स के होते हैं। IP एड्रेसेस फोर
ऑक्टेट होते हैं। उसी को मैं समझा रहा
हूं। 32 बिट्स कैसे होते हैं? देखो। यह
चार ऑक्टेट में डिवाइड होते हैं। पहला
ऑक्टेट यह। दूसरा यह तीसरा यह चौथा यह तो
फर्स्ट थ्री जो ऑक्टेट्स होते हैं यह
नेटवर्क को डिनोट करते हैं। नेटवर्क को और
लास्ट का जो होता है वो होस्ट को डिनोट
करता है। ठीक है? अब ये नेटवर्क क्या है?
होस्ट क्या है? हम उस पे भी आएंगे लेटर
ऑन। उसको भी समझेंगे। बस याद रखिएगा कि
पहला तीन जो नोटेशन है यानी 192 168.1 ये
नेटवर्क को डिनोट करते हैं। एक नेटवर्क को
और जो नेटवर्क का मतलब एक सबनेट को डिनोट
करते हैं। हम उस पे भी आएंगे क्या होता
है। एंड वन जो है वो होस्ट को डिनोट करते
हैं। यानी कि नंबर ऑफ डिवाइसेस यानी कि
नंबर ऑफ़ जो भी डिवाइसेस हैं उस पर्टिकुलर
नेटवर्क के अंदर में कितने आईपीस कितने
डिवाइसेस हो सकते हैं उसको ये डिनोट करते
हैं। ठीक है? तो यहां पर 1.1 है तो यानी
कि एक होस्ट सिंगल एक यानी कि एक होस्ट जो
है आपका यहां पे है। अब देखो ये जो चीज है
ये 1 फिर 1 तो यहां पे टू एक होस्ट को
असाइन है। मतलब कि वो जो नंबर है बेसिकली
ये वन का मतलब ये नहीं है कि नंबर ऑफ़
होस्ट वन है। नहीं वन का मतलब है ये जो
नंबर है ये असाइन है एक होस्ट को। होस्ट
को यह नंबर असाइन वो इसके जगह पर 2 3 4 5
कुछ भी हो सकता है। एनीथिंग इट कैन राइट
इट कैन बी एनीथिंग। चलिए अब यहां पर देखते
हैं। पहला जो ऑक्टेट है वो एट बिट्स का
होता है। अब मुझे यह बताइए आप लोग एक एक
बाइट में कितने बिट होते हैं? एक बाइट में
कितने बिट होते हैं? एनीवन एनीवन
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] नोस दिस?
एक
बाइट में कितने बिट होते हैं?
ये तो कॉमन चीज है। आप लोग ने पढ़ा भी
होगा। ऑब्वियस सी बात है। कॉलेजेस वगैरह
में भी ये ये चीजें पढ़ाते हैं। [हंसी] तो
ये तो नॉर्मल चीज है। इसको ऐसा नहीं होना
चाहिए कि आपको नहीं पता है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है? ओके। तो 8 बिट्स में 8 बिट्स में
वन मतलब 8 बिट्स जो होते हैं 1 बाइट में
होते हैं। 1 बाइट = 8 बिट्स। तो पहला जो
ऑक्टेट है वो 8 बिट्स का होता है। दूसरा
भी 8 बिट्स का होता है। तीसरा भी 8 बिट्स
का होता है। और चौथा भी 8 बिट्स का ही
होता है। यानी कि वन वन बाइट के चारों
ऑक्टेट होते हैं। सिंपल सा फंडा है। अब
चार ऑक्टेट हैं। 4 * ऑक्टेट
यानी कि 32 बिट्स यानी कि चार बाइट्स।
यानी IP एड्रेस जो होती है स्पेसिफिकली IP
वर्जन फोर एड्रेस। अब IP में भी दो
वर्जनंस होते हैं। IP वर्जन 4, IP वर्जन
सिक्स। सिक्स को लाया ही गया क्योंकि फोर
की कमी हो रही थी। फोर एग्जॉस्ट हो रहा
था। IP वर्जन 4 में जितने IPपी एड्रेसेस
हो सकते थे वो सारे IPपी एड्रेसेस किसी ना
किसी डिवाइस को असाइन हो गए। अब सोचो
कितने टाइम से और कितने बिलियन और
ट्रिलियन डिवाइसेस हैं इंटरनेट पे कि
लाखों की आईपी एड्रेस एग्जॉस्ट हो गई।
सोचो लाखों डिवाइसेस हैं। लाखों की आईपीस
एग्जॉस्ट हो गई। अब इसको
इससे बचने के लिए IP वर्जन सिक्स को ल्च
किया गया। क्योंकि उसमें उसमें पेंटालियन
मतलब बहुत IPपी एड्रेस है। उतनी आईपी
एड्रेस इतनी जल्दी खत्म ही नहीं हो सकती।
मतलब अनगिनत IPपी एड्रेस आप बोल सकते हो।
उसका भी फार्मूला मैं बताऊंगा क्यों है,
कैसे है तो आपको समझ में आ जाएगा। तो यहां
पे अगर कोई आपसे पूछे तो आप बता सकते हैं
IP एड्रेस इज अ 32 बिट बिट्स नंबर या फोर
बाइट्स नंबर। तो ये 32 बिट्स या फोर बिट्स
का एक नंबर होता है। तो यहीं पे मैंने वो
चीज लिखी हुई है। IPV वर्जन 4 = 32 बिट्स।
ठीक है? ईच पार्ट 8 बिट का एट बिट्स का
होता है। अब ये एट बिट्स क्या होते हैं?
किस तरीके से काम करते हैं? 0255 क्या
होता है? ये भी आपको लेटर ऑन समझ में
आएगा। अभी आपको कुछ नहीं समझ में आएगा।
0255 क्या है? आगे आपको सब समझ में आ
जाएगा। ध्यान से आज के सेशन को थोड़ा
देखिएगा क्योंकि आज का सेशन अगर आप थोड़ा
भी इधर-उधर मिस करेंगे, डिस्ट्रैक्ट होंगे
तो शायद आपको दोबारा से रिकॉर्डिंग बहुत
अच्छे से फिर दोबारा तबारा देखना पड़ेगा
समझने के लिए। एक बार में अभी आप देख
लेंगे तो एक बार और रिकॉर्डिंग देखेंगे
क्लियर हो जाएगा।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ओके? अब
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां पे क्या है
कि इसका बाइनरी कांसेप्ट
आपको समझना चाहिए। बाइनरी कांसेप्ट क्या
एग्जैक्टली बाइनरी कांसेप्ट होता है? तो
जैसे 192 है पहला ऑक्टेट का है तो इसका
बाइनरी नंबर 1100
हो जाता है। 168 है इसका क्या होता है?
अब ये मुझे बताइए डेसिमल को बाइनरी डेसिमल
अगर नंबर आपके पास है तो उसका बाइनरी नंबर
निकालना आप सबको आता है क्या? मुझे बताइए।
मुझे बताइए।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अगर आपके पास डेसिमल नंबर है तो डू यू
गाइस नो हाउ टू फाइंड द बाइनरी नंबर?
कई [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] लोगों को
पता होगा कॉलेज वालों लोगों को बहुत सिंपल
होता है। बहुत सिंपल होता है। जो भी नंबर
है उसको टू से डिवाइड करते जाओ। रिमाइंडर
जो और रिमाइंडर को ज़ीरो मतलब अगर रिमाइंडर
देखो क्या आ रहा है आपका? ज़ीरो आ रहा है,
वन आ रहा है। एंड तक उसको आपको डिवाइड
करते जाना है लास्ट लास्ट तक। जब हां
यस आनो गुड है। गुड है। गुड है। सही है।
आनो गुड इज़ इट्स गुड। तो एंड तक आपको उसको
डिवाइड करते जाना है। एंड जब वो लास्ट हो
जाएगी लास्ट मतलब लास्ट नंबर जो होगा उसके
बाद जो भी आपका आउटपुट आने वाला है उसको
नीचे से ऊपर के तरफ पढ़ा जाता है। तो जैसे
192 है तो इसको अगर हम डिवाइड करते हैं
जैसे लेट्स सी हम
ओके।
ओके। तो मैंने यहां पे एक वेट अह वाइट
बोर्ड ओपन कर लिया है। अब मान लो मुझे
इसका
मुझे इसका फाइंड करना है 192 का बाइनरी।
तो बहुत सिंपल सा ये बहुत सिंपल सा होता
है। मैं आपको अ बता देता हूं यहां पे फिर
भी। जैसे 192 है। तो जो भी नंबर है ना
सॉरी उसको टू से डिवाइड करने का ऐसे। तो
ठीक है। अब यहां पर टू से डिवाइड करेंगे
तो क्या आएगा? 2 * 9 18
इस तरह से आएगा। एंड यहां पे टू आ जाएगी।
राइट यहां पे फिर अब यहां से
ये आपका 12 आ गया।
हां राइट राइट। हां डबल वन वो आएगी यहां
पे। अब यहां पे जो आपका रिमाइंडर आता है।
अब यहां पर देखो द मेन थिंग इज द रिमाइंडर
रिमाइंडर आपका क्या आ रहा है? तो अगर मैं
यहां पर 192 को डिवाइड कर रहा हूं तो उसको
उसको डिवाइड करने से आपको आप किस तरीके से
डिवाइड करोगे इसको? तो 192 तो आप न से
करोगे तो ये टूल और 96 या 96 से आप करोगे
तो यहां पे 12 ये आ जाएगा आपका। यहां पे
इस तरीके से जीरो आ जाता है। तो यहां पे
इसी तरीके से एक-एक करके आपको डिवाइड करना
है। अब टू अब 12 को जो आपका रिमाइंडर जो
भी आपका बचता है यहां पर 96
अब यहां पर किसको डिवाइड करेंगे? यहां पर
96 आ गया मेरा कोसेंट जो है। अब यहां पे
किसको डिवाइड करेंगे? यहां पे 96 पे ये
ज़ीरो आ जा रहा है। अब यहां पे किसको
डिवाइड करेंगे? बताइए। जल्दी फास्ट बताइए।
फास्ट
हरी अप। हरी अप गाइस। जल्दी फास्ट बताओ।
96 को किससे डिवाइड करेंगे?
96 को 96 को टू से डिवाइड करेंगे। राइट?
टू से 96 को डिवाइड करेंगे। तो अब ये क्या
आएगा? अब ये क्या आएगा? फोर। तो यहां पे आ
जाएगा 8 1 आ गया सिक्स। एंड यहां पे आ
जाएगा
एट। तो ये 16 यहां पे भी ज़ीरो आ जाएगा।
यहां भी ज़ीरो आ गया। राइट? तो यहां पे अब
48 आ गया आपके पास। अब क्या आ गया आपका
रिमाइंडर? 48। अब 48 को टू से डिवाइड
करेंगे। सो जस्ट मैं इसको इधर
थोड़ा सा
उधर लेके चलते हैं।
अब क्या करेंगे? 48 को टू से डिवाइड
करेंगे। तो ये क्या आएगा? 2 * 2 = 4 एंड 2
* 4 = 8 राइट? ये ज़ीरो आ गया रिमाइंडर
रिमाइंडर आपका। अब 24 को टू से डिवाइड
करेंगे तो अब क्या आएगा? ये 12 टाइम्स 24
हो जाता है। ये मैं डायरेक्ट कर दे रहा
हूं। ठीक है? ठीक है? तो यहां पे क्या
हुआ? 2 टू ज़ीरो रिमाइंडर आ गया। अब 12
इसको टू से डिवाइड करेंगे। तो 2 * 6 = 12
होता है। 2 * 6 = 12 हो गया। अब यहां पे
ज़ीरो रिमाइंडर आ गया। अब सिक्स को टू से
डिवाइड करेंगे। ठीक है? कोई बात नहीं। इस
पे भी कर लो। 2 * 3 = 6 अब इसका रिमाइंडर
जीरो आ गया। अब थ्री को अब क्या आया?
थ्री। अब थ्री को टू से डिवाइड करेंगे तो
इसका क्या आएगा? 2 * 1 = 2। तो यहां पे
आया वन रिमाइंडर वन। अब यहां वन रिमाइंडर
आया। राइट? वी गॉट द रिमाइंडर एज़ वन। तो
यहां पे हम कशेंट को डिवाइड कर रहे थे ना।
जैसे थ्री को टू से डिवाइड। अब वन को टू
से डिवाइड करेंगे।
जब वन को यहां पे टू से डिवाइड करेंगे तो
यहां पे क्या आएगा? बताइए। रिमाइंडर क्या
आएगा? जब आप वन को टू से डिवाइड करोगे तो
रिमाइंडर क्या आएगा?
लेट मी नो। हां बिल्कुल न्यू बाइक का
हेलमेट पीछे रखा है। या करेक्ट
मिस खिलाड़ी। ओके।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] इसका
रिमाइंडर
हां इसको वन नहीं इसका रिमाइंडर वन आएगा।
वन आएगा। वन आएगा। ठीक है? इसका रिमाइंडर
वन आएगा। तो अब मेरा यहां पे कैलकुलेशन
कैसे होगा? नीचे से ऊपर की तरफ। यानी
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] कि नीचे से
ऊपर की तरफ का मतलब क्या हुआ? सबसे नीचे
हमारा सबसे लास्ट वाला होगा। फिर उसके बाद
उसके ऊपर होगा। फिर उसके बाद जी उसके ऊपर
ऊपर वाला ऐसे करेंगे। तो यहां पे जो मेरा
ये बाइनरी नंबर है 11 1 ये इसी से आया है।
1 1 फिर 1 0 2 0 3 0 4 0 5 0 6 0 6 0 तो
डबल वन पे छ जीरो यानी कि यहां पे जो आपको
दिख रहा होगा डबल वन पे 1 2 3 4 5 6 0 तो
ये आपका हां रिवर्स में हो जाता है।
बिल्कुल सही बात है। रिवर्स में आपका ये
काउंट होता है। तो अब जो है यहां पे आपका
ये वाला नंबर निकल के आता है। डबल वन पे छ
जीरो ये इसी तरीके से निकलता है। तो ये
बहुत इजी वे होता है बाइनरी निकालने का।
किसी भी डेसिमल का। इसी तरीके से आप
डिवाइड करते जाओ, करते जाओ, करते जाओ एंड
यू विल गेट द बाइनरी नंबर। उसी तरह से 168
का भी सेम चीज है। रिमाइंडर आप देखते जाओ
और करते जाओ। अब देखो एसओसी एल1 के तौर पे
आप एज एसओसी एल1 आपको ये बाइनरी ओनरी से
डील नहीं करना है। ये जस्ट मैंने एक इनफो
के लिए आपको बताया है। तो बिल्कुल टेंशन
फ्री रहिएगा। ठीक है? ओके।
अब IP एड्रेस में दो पार्ट होते हैं। जैसे
मैंने आपको यहां पर नेटवर्क होस्ट बताया
था। IP एड्रेस के दो पार्ट होते हैं। एक
पार्ट होता है नेटवर्क पार्ट, एक होता है
होस्ट पार्ट। तो फर्स्ट थ्री जो ऑक्टेट
होते हैं इसको हम नेटवर्क पार्ट बोलते
हैं। एंड लास्ट का जो ऑक्टेट होता है उसको
हम होस्ट पार्ट बोलते हैं। ठीक है? तो
नेटवर्क पार्ट का ये बाइनरी कुछ ऐसा है।
192, 168 एंड वन का एंड होस्ट पार्ट का
फिर वन का। ये बाइनरी फॉर्म में दिया है।
इसको इग्नोर कीजिए। ऐसा कोई रिक्वायरमेंट
नहीं है आपको। बट यहां पे समझना ये है कि
फर्स्ट थ्री पार्ट इज द नेटवर्क पार्ट।
लास्ट पार्ट इज द होस्ट पार्ट। अब इसकीेंस
आपको आगे चल के आज ही इसी सेशन में समझ
में आएगी कि नेटवर्क पार्ट क्या है? जब
सीआईडीआर पे आएंगे ना सीआईडीआर रेंज हम
समझेंगे सीआईडीआर नोटेशन तो हमको समझ में
आएगा कि इसका क्याेंस होता है। तो ये
नेटवर्क पार्ट हो गया एंड होस्ट पार्ट हो
गया। फर्स्ट थ्री इज़ नेटवर्क पार्ट।
नेटवर्क को डिनोट करता है। सबनेट को बताता
है कि किस सबनेट से बिलोंग करते हैं ये और
लास्ट वाला होस्ट मतलब कि डिवाइस को बताता
है जो भी होस्ट है। ठीक है? अब
अब आ जाते हैं नेटवर्क पार्ट के ऊपर।
नेटवर्क पार्ट को समझते हैं। तो नेटवर्क
पार्ट जो है आइडेंटिफाइड आइडेंटिफाई व्हिच
नेटवर्क द डिवाइस बिलोंग टू। यानी कि ये
किस नेटवर्क से बिलोंग करता है ये डिवाइस?
यह बताता है फर्स्ट जो थ्री ऑक्टेट होते
हैं। जैसे कि आप इसको ऐसे सोचिए एक सिटी
या एक एरिया एक एक एड्रेस है तो उसका कोई
एरिया हो या एक सिटी हो वो नेटवर्क पार्ट
आप उसको उस तरीके से समझिए कि नेटवर्क
पार्ट क्या होता है? एक एड्रेस का कोई एक
सिटी मतलब एड्रेस आपने दिया है कंप्लीट
एड्रेस तो उसका जो सिटी होगा या उस एरिया
को वो नेटवर्क पार्ट आप बोल सकते हैं।
एग्जांपल क्या है? जैसे 192 168.10 में
नेटवर्क पार्ट क्या होगा? 192 168.1 तक का
यह नेटवर्क पार्ट होगा। यह ऑलरेडी क्लियर
है। अब यहां पे इसका मतलब यह हुआ ऑल
डिवाइसेस विथ 192 168.1x
x का मतलब कि ये वेरिएबल है क्योंकि लास्ट
वाला हम अभी कंसीडर नहीं कर रहे हैं। आर
इन द सेम नेटवर्क। मतलब जितने भी डिवाइसेस
हैं जिनके IPपी एड्रेसेस 192 168.1 से
शुरू हो रही होगी वो सेम नेटवर्क में ही
फॉल करेंगे। क्योंकि वो सेम सबनेट से
बिलोंग करते हैं। सबनेट पे हम आएंगे तो
उसको और भी क्लियर आपको मैं करूंगा और भी
आपको अच्छे से समझ में वो आ जाएगा। सो ऑल
डिवाइसेस विद दिस पर्टिकुलर फर्स्ट थ्री
सेम ऑक्टेट बिलोंग्स टू द सेम नेटवर्क।
इसका मतलब ये होता है। तो पूरा का पूरा
नेटवर्क के बारे में बताने के लिए हमारा
जो है ये फर्स्ट थ्री ऑक्टेट होते हैं
नेटवर्क पार्ट। अब आते हैं होस्ट पार्ट पे
जो लास्ट वाला एक छोटा सा पार्ट है लास्ट
वाला जो डॉट के बाद वाला उसको समझते हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] दिस
आइडेंटिफाई द स्पेसिफिक डिवाइस इनसाइड द
नेटवर्क। एक डिवाइस को यह आइडेंटिफाई करता
है कि यह कौन सा डिवाइस है भाई? इसको
आइडेंटिफाई करता है। इसका आप क्या समझ
सकते हैं? हाउस नंबर इन अ सिटी। अब एक
एड्रेस है। एड्रेस में जो नेटवर्क पार्ट
है वो क्या है? एक एरिया या एक सिटी को
बोल लीजिए और उसमें एक घर का जो नंबर होगा
फ्लैट नंबर, हाउस नंबर वो जो होगा वो वो
होस्ट पार्ट होगा कि एक पर्टिकुलर हाउस ये
पर्टिकुलर घर यही घर है। समझ में आया? अरे
एक उस एरिया में यह घर तो वह जो एरिया है
वह नेटवर्क हो गया। यह घर जो है वह होस्ट
हो गया। अब इसी तरीके से इस पर्टिकुलर
आईपी में 10 जो है ये होस्ट पार्ट हो गया।
यानी कि डिवाइस नंबर 10 इन दैट नेटवर्क।
यानी कि जो 10थ नंबर का डिवाइस है हम उसको
डिनोट कर रहे हैं उस पर्टिकुलर नेटवर्क
में। 15 हुआ तो 15th नंबर ऑफ 15थ नंबर
डिवाइस को हम डिनोट कर रहे हैं। इसका मतलब
ये भी हुआ कि अगर आपको कोई IP एक नेटवर्क
में 15 करके मिल रही है तो ये तो कंफर्म
है कि 14 डिवाइसेस तो है ही है ही उस
नेटवर्क में जो कनेक्टेड मतलब जिनको IP
असाइन हुई है। हो सकता है 15 से भी ज्यादा
हो बट 15 तक अगर आपको मिला है तो 14 तो है
ही। उसके अलावा अगर आपको 18 मिल जा रहा है
तो 17 तो है ही। इस तरीके से हम थोड़ा सा
आईडिया ले लेते हैं। ओके? ओके।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब ये तो IP एड्रेस में बेसिक कुछ चीजें
हो गई। अभी IP एड्रेस का भी और भी चीजें
IPपी एड्रेस की बची है। अभी हम उस पे
आएंगे। बट अब यहां पे थोड़ी सी हम
सबनेटिंग को समझते हैं। क्योंकि सबनेटिंग
मैं बार-बार बोल रहा हूं कि एक ही सबनेट
से एक ही सबनेट से वो समझते हैं। क्योंकि
ये काफी लोग इसको लेकर कंफ्यूज होते हैं।
और आज मैं आपकी कंफ्यूजन दूर कर दूंगा।
बहुत इजी वे में बताऊंगा, समझाऊंगा। इसको
बहुत इजी वे में समझिएगा। सबनेटिंग आपको
आज के बाद से प्रॉब्लम नहीं क्रिएट करेगा।
ठीक है? तो समझ लीजिए। सबनेटिंग क्या होता
है? सबनेटिंग का मतलब होता है एक नेटवर्क
को छोटे-छोटे नेटवर्क में डिवाइड कर देना।
एक नेटवर्क को छोटे-छोटे नेटवर्क में
डिवाइड कर दो। सबनेटिंग हो गया। इससे इसका
बेनिफिट क्या है? एक बेटर सिक्योरिटी
मिलती है, बेटर परफॉर्मेंस मिलता है। एंड
मैनेजमेंट जो है वो इज़ियर हो जाता है।
क्योंकि IP एड्रेसेस पूल बहुत बड़े-बड़े
होते हैं। कई ऐसे ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस जो होते
हैं बड़े-बड़े मान लो Google है, Microsoft
है लाइक X X है। अब ये एक बहुत बड़े-बड़े
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस हैं। इनके पास कोई दो चार,
10, 100,000 आईपीस नहीं होती। इनके पास
लाखों में भी आईपी हो सकती हैं। और उन
आईपी को मैनेज करना बहुत मुश्किल हो जाएगा
अगर सबनेटिंग ना हो। ठीक है? तो सबनेटिंग
वहां पे वो रोल प्ले करता है। अब उसी
सबनेटिंग में एक सीआईडीआर नोटेशन होता है
जो क्लासलेस क्लास क्लासलेस इंटर डोमेन
राउटिंग एक एक टर्म होता है। उसके ऊपर भी
हम आएंगे। ये सीआईडीआर नोटेशन होता है। अब
आपने कई बार ना लinक्स वगैरह जब आप चलाते
होंगे या ऐसे जनरली भी कहीं पे आपने इस
तरह से कोई एक आईपी एड्रेस देखी होगी। कभी
आप में से किसी ने देखा है क्या? इस तरह
की कोई आपको आईपी कहीं पे मिली हो बग
बाउंट या कर रहे हो। कुछ ऐसा कर रहे हो
192 168 और 10 24 या कोई भी कोई भी IP 24
या 86
इस तरह का कुछ आपको आपने कभी नोटिस किया
है कहीं पे आपको मिला है कहीं पे आप लोगों
को [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सो लेट मी नो इफ यू हैव फाउंड सच थिंग्स
मिला ओके
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ओके ग्रेट मिला
है तो अब इसको मैं आपको समझाता हूं कि ये
क्या होता है। देखो 24 का मतलब होता है
24 बिट्स नेटवर्क को डिनोट कर रहे हैं और
एट बिट्स होस्ट को डिनोट कर रहे हैं। इसका
मतलब क्या है? मैं आपको समझाता हूं। देखो
टोटल बिट्स कितने हैं आईपी एड्रेस में?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
IP एड्रेस में टोटल बिट्स कितने हैं?
जल्दी बताओ जल्दी। देखो फास्ट रिप्लाई
करोगे तभी मैं समझूंगा कि आपका ध्यान इधर
है। फास्ट
और 10 लोग मस्त रिप्लाई करते हैं। बाकी
लोग मस्त बस देखते रहते हैं बैठे हुए हैं।
क्या टेंशन है रिप्लाई करने दो। हम तो
बैठे हैं। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
32 बिट्स के आईपीip एड्रेस 32 बिट का होता
है। अब यहां स्लैश 24 का मतलब होता है जो
भी स्लैश के बाद जो भी नंबर होगा वो नंबर
नेटवर्क को डिनोट करेगा। एंड जो नंबर बच
जाएगा 32 में से वो होस्ट्स को डिनोट
करेगा।
बस
इतना ही समझ लीजिए। अब इसको हम बाद में
यूज़ करने वाले हैं कैलकुलेट करने के लिए
कि नंबर ऑफ़ आईपीस कैलकुलेट हम करेंगे
कितनी आईपी निकल रही है एक पर्टिकुलर इस
सीआईडीआर नोटेशन या और नोटेशन से। ठीक है?
ये क्लियर हो गया आपको कि स्लश 24 का मतलब
24 बिट्स का नेटवर्क है और 8 बिट्स होस्ट
के लिए है। ये तो आपको समझ में आ चुका
होगा। ठीक है? चलिए अब आगे की तरफ बढ़ते
हैं। धीरे-धीरे मैं आपको ले चलूंगा प्यार
प्यार से एकदम
बच्चों की तरह थोड़ा। नहीं तो दिमाग से
ऐसा उड़ेगा कि फिर जल्दी आएगा नहीं आपके
दिमाग में।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] ठीक
है? हां।
अरे होस्ट्स मतलब डिवाइस का मतलब क्या
होता है यार? होस्ट थ्री तो वही हुए हैं
भाई बट लास्ट पार्ट इज फॉर डिवाइसेस तो
डिवाइसेस होस्ट सब एक ही समझ लो सब एक ही
मान लो ठीक है वही है होस्ट डिवाइसेस सब
एक ही है
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है चलिए ये हो गया अब यहां पे मैं
नेक्स्ट पे आता हूं और इसको थोड़ा समझिएगा
ठीक है पहले हम सीआईडीआर को समझते हैं।
यहां पे आपने देखा सीआईडीआर नोटेशन कुछ इस
तरीके से होता है। अब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] हम सीआईडीआर
क्या होता है? सीआईडीआर का मतलब होता है
क्लासलेस इंटर डोमेन राउटिंग। एक क्लासलेस
जिसका कोई क्लास नहीं है। इंटर डोमेन
राउटिंग। अब देखो सीआईडीआर इंप्रूव्स आईपी
एड्रेस मैनेजमेंट बाय अलाउंग मोर
फ्लैक्सिबल सबनेटिंग एंड एफिशिएंट एलोकेशन
ऑफ़ आईपी एड्रेसेस सिग्निफिकेंटली
रिड्यूसिंग द वेस्ट। ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस यूज़
सीआईडीआर टू एलोकेट IPपी एड्रेसेस
फ्लैक्सिबली एंड एफिशिएंटली इन द नेटवर्क।
सीआईडीआर का यूज मेनली बड़े ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस
के द्वारा किया जाता है। ठीक है?
छोटे-मोटे ऑ्गेनाइजेशन सीआईडीआर को
यूटिलाइज नहीं करते हैं। इसका यूज़ इसलिए
किया जाता है क्योंकि सीआईडीआर एक ऐसी
यूटिलिटी है जिससे एफिशिएंटली IP एड्रेसेस
के बहुत बड़े-बड़े पूल को एलोकेट किया जाता
है डिवाइसेस को। लाखों में IPपी एड्रेस ले
रखा है किसी कंपनी ने। अब उसको उसके पास
हजारों डिवाइसेस हैं नेटवर्क में। उन सबको
IPपी एड्रेस देनी है तो कोई IPपी एड्रेस
छूट ना जाए। कोई IPपी एड्रेस फालतू में ना
रह जाए। कोई एक ही आईपी एड्रेस मल्टीपल को
असाइन ना हो जाए या कुछ ऐसा मतलब फालतू का
वेस्टेज ना हो। फालतू की किसी तरह का लाइक
ओवरलैपिंग ना हो किसी भी तरह के उससे बचने
के लिए सीआईडीआर का यूज़ किया जाता है। बस
यही है सीआईडीआर नथिंग एल्स। जब आप
Facebook, Google इन सब की देखेंगे
सीआईडीआर वगैरह तो इनकी सीआईडीआर प्रेजेंट
होती है। मैं आपको वो भी चीज दिखा दूंगा।
फिलहाल के लिए मैं इसको क्लोज करके यहां
पे आपको वो चीज थोड़ा सा
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अरन
हु इज ये वेबसाइट है। इस पे मैं जाता हूं।
ठीक है?
जब आप इस [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
वेबसाइट पे आएंगे एंड यहां पर
लेट मी शो यू। ओके कंट्रोल आर यह लोड नहीं
हुआ ठीक से तो वापस से रीलोड करते हैं।
हम अब यहां पे मैंने Facebook सर्च किया।
लेट्स सी व्हाट इज इफ आई एम गेटिंग
समथिंग। Facebook सर्च किया। अब यहां पे
मुझे Facebook के नेटवर्क्स मिल गए। यहां
पे ये बहुत सारे नेटवर्क्स हैं आपको यहां
पे दिख रहे हैं। दीज़ ऑल आर द नेटवर्क्स आई
एम गेटिंग। राइट? और ये ऑर्गेनाइजेशन मिल
गई यहां पे। ये आपके कस्टमर्स वगैरह जो भी
है ये सारी चीज़ मिल गई। अब यहां पे ये ये
एएसए नंबर मिलता है। हमें Facebook का
एएसएन नंबर मिलता है। जब हम इस पे क्लिक
करते हैं तो एएसए की यहां पे डिटेल वगैरह
जो भी चीजें हैं वो सारी चीजें आपको मिल
जाती हैं। यहां पे कुछ इस तरीके से एएसए
ये आपको मिल जाता है। अब इसी पर्टिकुलर
रेंज में जब आप देखेंगे तो यहां पे
Facebook का एक नेट 209 नेटवर्क है। बहुत
अलग-अलग नेटवर्क्स होते हैं। जैसे ये आप
देखो यहां पे अलग-अलग नेटवर्क्स होते हैं।
अब यहां पे आपको एक सीआईडीआर रेंज मिलेगी।
कोई भी नेटवर्क जब आप ओपन करेंगे यू विल
सी द सीआईडीआर रेंज। यह आपको सीआईडीआर
रेंज आपको यहां पे मिल गई। तो 20970
125 92 30 ये सीआईडीआर रेंज मिली। अब इस
सीआईडीआर रेंज में एक IPपी एड्रेस बहुत
सारे आईपी एड्रेससेस होंगे। तो अब मैं
क्या करता हूं? सीआईडीआर टू आईपी रेंज। यह
मैं सर्च करता हूं। एक यूटिलिटी ओपन करता
हूं आईपी एड्रेस गाइड का। और मैं यहां पे
यह सीआईडीआर को पेस्ट कर देता हूं। अब मैं
कैलकुलेट करता हूं। तो मुझे यहां पे यह
बताएगा कि इस सीआईडीआर में कितने IPपी
एड्रेसेस के पूल हैं अलॉटेड हैं। तो आप
देखो यहां पे टोटल जो होस्ट है इस
सीआईडीआर रेंज में ओनली फोर होस्ट है।
ओनली फोर। क्यों? क्योंकि यहां पे स्लैश
30 है। यानी कि सिर्फ टू बिट्स का ही बचा
हुआ है अपना होस्ट वाला। समझ में आ रहा
है? टू बिट्स वाला। क्योंकि 32 बिट्स का
आईपी होता है। 30 तो नेटवर्क के लिए ही
सिर्फ दे दिया गया है। तो टू बिट्स बचा
हुआ है। तो इसमें बहुत कम होस्ट होंगे। तो
यहां पे सिर्फ चार होस्ट जो है इसके अंदर
में प्रेजेंट है। अब इसी तरीके से जो बहुत
सारे नेटवर्क्स होंगे जिसमें बहुत ज्यादा
आईपीस होंगे। मैं आपको अभी दिखाता हूं।
लेट मी सी इफ देयर इज़ एन एनी बिगर
नेटवर्क।
हां, 138 वाली बिगर नेटवर्क है। ठीक है।
इसको ओपन करते हैं। ये नेटवर्क। इसका आईपी
रेंज निकालते हैं। इसका सीआईडीआर देखते
हैं। यस। इसका भी सीआईडीआर नहीं इसका भी
ओके। लेट्स सी।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
कैलकुलेट करते हैं। इसमें भी चार होस्ट है
क्योंकि इसका भी 30 में है। कोई बड़ा
सीआईडीआर रेंज निकाल के देखते हैं इसका।
कोई इफ वी आर गेटिंग चलो इसको मैं ओपन कर
लेता हूं न्यू टैब्स में।
लेट्स सी इफ सम बिग सीआईडीआर वी आर
गेटिंग।
इनका है 30 30 30
30 30 30 अरे भैया सब 30 वाले हैं। नीचे
एक बार चलते हैं। हम हम
या 48 वाली है। ओके 28 वाली है। 30 30
कोई कम वाली नहीं है ना? ठीक है। 28 वाली
है। इसको इसको ओपन कर लेते हैं। एंड लेट्स
कैलकुलेट दिस वन। हाउ मेनी डिवाइसेस आर
देयर? सो यहां पे ज्यादा होंगे। यहां पे
देखो यहां पे 16 डिवाइसेस हैं आपके। 16
डिवाइसेस हैं जो इसमें प्रेजेंट है। यानी
16 जो है होस्ट्स जो है इसमें प्रेजेंट
है। तो ये तो इसका हो गया। Google का भी
आप करेंगे। जैसे मैं यहां पे
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] Google का
करता हूं। लेट्स सी इफ देयर इज़ सम Google
का। हां, यहां पे इसके मल्टीपल एसए नंबर
है। तो यहां पे मैं देखता हूं यहां पे
Google का। तो मैं इसमें से 209 वाली ले
लेता हूं। इसमें इफ देयर इज सम इसमें 29
वाली है।
इसमें 24 है। गुड
29 है। वी विल सी समथिंग हियर। लेट्स सी।
हां जी। 29 24 इसको रहने देते हैं। 29
रिमूव इट। 48 ना 19 है। इसको रहने देते
हैं। 20 है। इसको भी रहने देते हैं। 18 है
गुड वन।
विल गेट गुड नंबर ऑफ होस्ट्स 48 ना 28
रिक्वायर्ड नहीं है। 30 इसकी रिक्वायरमेंट
नहीं है। यह Facebook वाली है ना तो इनकी
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। अब मैं यहां पे 18
वाली जो हमारे पास है इस सीआईडीआर को कॉपी
करता हूं। एंड यहां पे सीआईडीआर रेंज में
इसको हम कैलकुलेट करते हैं। लाइक हाउ मेनी
होस्ट आर देयर? सो मैं यहां पे कैलकुलेट
करता हूं। एंड यहां पे आपको देख आप
देखेंगे कि यहां पे 16384
होस्ट्स इसमें हैं। यानी इतने IPपी एड्रेस
में एलोकेटेड हो रहे हैं। इस इतने IPपी
एड्रेसेस यहां पे IPपी एड्रेसेस का पूल
है। तो ऐसे तो ये एक सीआईडीआर में 16,000
है। ऐसे मल्टीपल सीआईडीआर्स हैं। मल्टीपल
एएसएन नंबर्स होते हैं और तो उनमें
अलग-अलग आईपी एड्रेस के पूल होते हैं। तो
मेरे कहने का सेंस ये है कि यहां पे बहुत
बड़े-बड़े आईपी रेंजेस को जब हम आईपी
रेंजेस की बात करते हैं तो उस केस में हम
बात करते हैं सीआईडीआर की एंड उसी लिए
सीआईडीआर का यूज़ किया जाता है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सिंपल सा
फंडा है कि जब सीआईडीआर का उसके लिए यूज़
आप करेंगे तो वहां पे आप बात कर रहे हैं
बहुत बड़े ऑर्गेनाइजेशन बहुत बड़े आईपी
पूल को आप एफिशिएंटली जो है वो क्या कर
रहे हैं? एलोकेशन की बात कर रहे हैं। तो
जो बड़े-बड़े ऑ्गेनेशंस हैं वो सीआईडीआर का
यूज़ करते हैं IP एड्रेस को एलोकेट करने के
लिए एफिशिएंटली अपने नेटवर्क के अंदर
डिवाइसेस को। ठीक है? बस अब व्हाट इज़ 24
सबनेट? स्लैश 24 सबनेट क्या है? देखो इन
IP एड्रेसिंग द स्लैश 24 नोटेशन रेफर्स टू
अ सबनेट मास्क विद 24 बिट्स डेडिकेटेड टू
द नेटवर्क पोर्शन। जैसे मैंने पहले बताया
कि 24 बिट्स नेटवर्क पोर्शन को डेडिकेटेड
है ऑफ़ एन एड्रेस। दिस लीव्स 8 बिट्स
अवेलेबल फॉर द होस्ट पोर्शन और एट बिट्स
अवेलेबल है फॉर द होस्ट पोर्शन। सबनेट
मास्क डिफाइन हाउ एन IPपी एड्रेस इज़
डिवाइडेड इंटू नेटवर्क एंड होस्ट
सेगमेंट्स। सो सबनेट मास्क क्या करता है
ना यही बताता है कि IP कैसे IP एड्रेस जो
है वो नेटवर्क सेगमेंट में और होस्ट
सेगमेंट में डिवाइडेड है। किस तरीके से
डिवाइडेड है? कितना नेटवर्क सेगमेंट को
मिला है? कितना होस्ट सेगमेंट को अलॉट हुआ
है जो बिट्स है। बस अगर आपसे कोई भी पूछे
आप टेक्निकली इस तरीके से आंसर कर सकते
हैं। फोर स्कल का सुपर चैट आया हुआ है।
चलिए धन्यवाद भाई फॉर स्कल साहब। हालांकि
सुपर चैट्स की जरूरत अब नहीं होती है। बट
स्टिल थैंक यू वेरी मच। IP एड्रेस कोई भी
पूछे आपको सबनेट क्या होता है? तो आप
सीधा-सीधा जवाब दे दीजिएगा। सबनेट मास्क
क्या होता है? सबनेट मास्क जो है वो
डिफाइन करता है कि IP एड्रेस किस तरीके से
डिवाइडेड है? नेटवर्क पार्ट में और होस्ट
पार्ट में। नेटवर्क पार्ट को कितना बिट
मिला है? होस्ट पार्ट को कितना बिट मिला
है? व्हिच इंटर्न्स डिटरमाइंस द नंबर ऑफ़
आईपीस अवेलेबल इन अ गिवन रेंज। एंड इससे
यह पता चलता है नंबर ऑफ़ आईपीस इन अ गिवन
रेंज। इसी से पता चलता है कि इस पर्टिकुलर
रेंज में कितनी IP एड्रेसेस होंगी। यह अब
यह कैलकुलेशन भी है कि कितनी IPपी एड्रेस
होंगी भाई। यह भी कैलकुलेशन है। यह भी हम
देखेंगे भाई कैलकुलेट करेंगे। अगर आपको
करना है। तो मैं करा दूंगा। बिल्कुल।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] चलिए ये यहां
तक मुझे मुझे पहले सभी लोग रिप्लाई
कीजिएगा। देखो बैठ के चुपचाप देखना नहीं
है। रिप्लाई भी करना है। तो मुझे सभी लोग
रिप्लाई कीजिए। रिसोंड रिसोंड कीजिए कि
यहां तक आपका सब क्लियर हुआ सभी का। प्लीज
लेट मी नो फास्ट गाइस।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
बंटी मिली थी 2000। वाओ क्या बात है? फोर
स्कल कांग्रेचुलेशंस फॉर बंटी। उसमें से
40 मुझे सुपर चैट कर दिया। थैंक यू वेरी
मच। एंड आई एम वेरी हैप्पी। आपको बंटी
मिली है 2000 की। सो कांग्रेचुलेशंस।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] समझ
में आ गया? ठीक है? अब यहां पे आते हैं।
हाउ मेनी IP एड्रेसेस इन अ स्लश 24 सबनेट?
इसको अब समझते हैं कैलकुलेट करके। ठीक है?
आपको समझ में आ जाएगा। बहुत क्लियरली समझ
में आ जाएगा। ठीक है? बहुत इजी वे में मैं
बताऊंगा। इतने इजी वे में शायद आपको आज तक
किसी ने बताया नहीं होगा या आपने शायद
देखा नहीं होगा। देखो 24 सबनेट प्रोवाइड्स
अ टोटल ऑफ़ 256 IPपी एड्रेससेस। अब ये 256
आईपी एड्रेस दे रहा है। कैसे दे रहा है
उसको समझेंगे। कैसे कैलकुलेट होता है?
देखो
टोटल IPपी कैलकुलेट होती है 2 टू दी पावर
32। टोटल 32 बिट का आईपी एड्रेस होता है।
तो जिस जितना सबनेट यहां पे जितने
सीआईडीआई नोटेशन में जो यहां पे सबनेट
दिया हुआ है सबनेट का नंबर दिया है उसको
32 से माइनस कर लेने का।
बस तो [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यहां पे 32 - सबनेट तो 2 पावर 32 - 24 हो
गया क्योंकि स्लश 24 है। अगर स्लैश 16
होता तो -16 होता। स्लश 8 होता तो -8
होता। एंड यहां पे अब बच जाता है 2 टू दी
पावर 8 और 2 टू दी पावर जब एट होती है
उसको जब आप करोगे टू को एट टाइम्स
मल्टीप्लाई तो नंबर आता है 256 तो टोटल
नंबर ऑफ आईपी यहां पे हो जाती है 256 बट
अगर यहां पे सेम जगह पे स्लश 24 ना होके
देखो
हम
अरे यार यह हटेगा कैसे भाई
अच्छा ये ऐसे हटता है। वाह
हां अच्छा ऐसे भी होगा ना? ठीक है। चलो अब
यहां पे हमने यहां पे स्लश
24 की बात की। थोड़ा यह मोटा वाला कौन सा
है भाई?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
इतना पतला कैसे हो रहा है यार ये
थोड़े टाइम पहले तो मोटा हो गया था
हम अब यहां पे हमने स्लश 24 की बात की तो
यहां पे 2 टू दी पावर सिंपल 32 टोटल 32
बिट का आईपी है -2 हो गया एंड यहां पे इज
इक्वल टू आया 2 टू दी पावर 8 ये 256 सिक्स
हो गई। अब सोचो यहां पे अगर यही स्लश
16 होता तो इसमें IPपी एड्रेसेस ज्यादा
होते या कम होते? बताइए मुझे। स्लश 24 में
256 IPपी एड्रेस आ रही है। कैलकुलेट करके।
अब अगर स्लश 16 होता तो यहां पे IPपी
एड्रेसेस इसमें कम होंगे या ज्यादा होंगे?
मुझे बताइए।
प्लीज लेट मी नो।
यहां पे कम होंगे IPपी एड्रेसेस या ज्यादा
आएंगे?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सभी लोग आंसर कीजिए। देखता हूं मैं कितने
लोगों का आंसर सही है, गलत है।
करेक्ट ज्यादा होंगे। ऑब्वियस सी बात है।
2 टू दी पावर 32 - 16 होगा। तो यहां पे इज
इक्वल टू क्या आ जाएगा? टू यहां पे 2 टू
दी पावर
सिक्स एंड 16 2 टू दी पावर 16 तो यहां पे
अब 32 में से 16 जाएगा तो 16 जो है आपके
पास आ जाएगा यानी 2 टू दी पावर 16 टू को
16 टाइम्स आप मल्टीप्लाई करो तो उतना यहां
पे IP एड्रेस उतनी IPपी एड्रेस जो है यहां
पे आपको मिल जाएगी जो भी IPपी एड्रेसेस है
वो आपको मिल जाएगी। मैं कैलकुलेट
कैलकुलेटर में होता है क्या यह पावर वाला
आई डोंट नो लेट्स फाइंड आउट टू टू दी आई
थिंक कैलकुलेटर में पावर का ऑप्शन नहीं
होता है शायद होता है क्या
हम हम हम
नहीं होता ना अच्छा हां होता है 2 टू दी
पावर 16 65536
तो यहां पे आ जाना है 65000
500 36 इतनी IP एड्रेसेस इसमें होंगी। अब
यह 65536
से आपको कुछ याद आ रहा है? आपको कुछ आप
कुछ रिलेट कर पा रहे हो क्या इस नंबर से?
यह नंबर से आप कुछ रिलेट कर पा रहे हो
क्या? 65536
से
आर यू रिलेटिंग समथिंग? यह नंबर किस कोई
चीज होती है? ये कुछ नंबर होता है ये?
पोर्ट्स। यस। टोटल नंबर ऑफ पोर्ट्स।
करेक्ट।
एक नेटवर्क [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] में
टोटल नंबर ऑफ पोर्ट्स जो है इतने होते
हैं। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तो अब
यह चीज आपको देखो यह चीज तो आपको समझ में
आ गई होगी।
ये चीज आपको समझ में आ गई होगी कि ये
कैलकुलेशन किस तरीके से हो रहा है। ईजी वे
में समझ में आ गया कैलकुलेशन कैसे हो रहा
है?
सभी को समझ में आ गया? कैलकुलेशन ईजी था?
टफ तो नहीं था?
बताइए। अब [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
देखिए अब यहां पे जो आईपीस आई है मान लो
256 आईपीस आई हैं। बट यहां पर 256 जो
आईपीस हैं उसमें से जो फर्स्ट आईपी है और
जो लास्ट आईपी है वो हमारे
काम का नहीं होता। वो रिजर्व होता है।
उसको आप यूज़ नहीं ले सकते। तो पहला IP जो
होता है वह नेटवर्क एड्रेस होता है।
फर्स्ट IP जो कि 1921 168.0.0 है। यानी कि
0 से 256 तो टोटल जो है यहां पे आपकी जो
IP है यूज़बल वो 254 यूज़बल IPपी होगी। 256
है टोटल IPपी एड्रेसेस टोटल IPपी एड्रेस
256 है। इसमें से जो दो IP है फर्स्ट और
लास्ट IP ये आपके काम की नहीं है। दिस इज़
नॉट ऑफ योर यूज़ केस। तो यहां पे फर्स्ट
आईपी नेटवर्क IP होती है। नेटवर्क एड्रेस
होता है जैसे 1828.0
व्हिच आइडेंटिफाई द सबनेट इटसेल्फ जो
सबनेट को ही आइडेंटिफाई करने के लिए यूज़
में लिया जाता है। एंड दूसरा जो होता है
वो ब्रॉडकास्ट IPपी एड्रेस होता है जो
लास्ट वाला IPपी एड्रेस होता है वो होता
है 192 168 और 0.255 अब मैं ये जो
स्टार्टिंग का ये जो एग्जांपल मैं ले रहा
हूं 192 168.0
ये एज अ एग्जांपल मैं दे रहा हूं ये यहां
पे नंबर चेंज भी हो सकता है। यह 192 168.1
भी हो सकता है या कुछ भी हो सकता है। तो
अभी के लिए यहां जो वाला पहला IP और लास्ट
वाला जो 255 वाली जो IP है ये जो IP है
आपकी ये होती है ब्रॉडकास्ट एड्रेस। ये
किस लिए यूज़ आता है? यूज़्ड टू कम्युनिकेट
विद ऑल होस्ट्स इन द सबनेट। इसका ही यूज़
करके जितने भी होस्ट्स हैं उनसे
कम्युनिकेशन हो पाती है, कम्युनिकेट कर
पाते हैं। तो इसलिए टोटल यूज़बल IPपी जो
होती है वो आपकी होती है 254 IP और इसमें
भी सबसे पहला जो यूज़बल आईपी जो सबसे पहला
यूज़बल आईपी है जो कौन सा होगा? सबसे पहला
यूज़बल आईपी बताइए। इस इस पूरे आईपी में
सबसे पहला यूज़बल आईपी कौन सा होगा? बताइए।
गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग। सबसे पहला यूज़बल
आईपी कौन सा होगा?
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
लेट मी नो
सबसे पहला जिसको आप यूज कर सकते हैं।
बिल्कुल सही
बिल्कुल सही वो होगा 192
168.01
ये आपका सबसे पहला यूज़बल आईपी होगा। और ये
जो आईपी है वो जनरली किसको असाइन होता है
बताइए मुझे। आप लोग तो बहुत
शार्प लोग हैं। शार्प माइंडेड आपको पता
होगा शायद। यह जो पहली आईपी यूसेबल आईपी
है, पहली जो यूज़ हो रही है, वो जनरली
नॉर्मली किसको असाइन होता है?
बिल्कुल सही। वो असाइन होता है आपके राउटर
को या गेटवे को असाइन होता है। जो आपका
राउटर होता है या जो भी गेटवे होता है,
राउटर का मतलब क्या है? गेटवे का मतलब
क्या है? एक गेट आपके इंटरनल नेटवर्क और
एक्सटर्नल नेटवर्क के बीच का एक गेट यानी
जो आपका इंटरनल नेटवर्क है आपका लोकल
नेटवर्क और बाहर की दुनिया से जो आप
कनेक्ट कर रहे हैं तो आप राउटर के थ्रू कर
रहे हैं एक गेटवे के थ्रू कर रहे हैं। तो
उस गेटवे का या राउटर का जो आईपी जनरली
होता है वो फर्स्ट यूसेबल आईपी ही अलॉट
होता है। आप देख सकते हैं। हालांकि इट इज़
नॉट मैंडेटरी। कोई और
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] भी आईपी हो
सकती है। बट जनरली इट्स प्रैक्टिस की
फर्स्ट यूसेबल आईपी अलॉट होती है। समझ में
आ गया? यह क्लियर हो गया। चलिए,
अब आते हैं यहां पे
कुछ कॉमन सबनेट्स को देखते हैं। कुछ कॉमन
सबनेट्स को। अब देखो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] कुछ कॉमन
सबनेट्स में स्लश 24, स्लश 16 एंड स्लैश
एट होता है। अब स्लैश एट तो बहुत कम आपको
देखने को मिलेगा। इसका भी रीज़न मैं
बताऊंगा। स्लैश 24 मोस्टली आपको देखने को
मिलेगा। लोकल नेटवर्क्स में जो लायन होते
हैं जैसे आपका जो नेटवर्क है जैसे मेरा जो
नेटवर्क है जैसे अभी मैं जो नेटवर्क यूज़
कर रहा हूं इसमें स्लैश 24 ही देखने को
मिलेगा। टोटल डिवाइसेस मेरे नेटवर्क में
254 यूज़बल IP है। इतने डिवाइसेस कनेक्ट हो
सकते हैं। राउटर को छोड़ दो भाई कनेक्ट हो
सकते हैं। इसका
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] जो सबनेट
होता है वो 255 255 255.0 होता है। यानी
कि फर्स्ट थ्री जो है आपका सिमिलर है।
लास्ट का आपका जो नंबर है वो चेंज होता
रहेगा। एंड उतनी डिवाइसेस आपके नेटवर्क
में कनेक्ट होती रहेंगी। उसके बाद स्लश 16
है। अब मैंने ये तो कैलकुलेट करना सिखा
दिया है आपको कि स्लैश 16 में कितनी आईपीस
होंगी। अभी कैलकुलेट भी करा हमने 65534
या 35 जो भी है ये आपकी टोटल नंबर ऑफ़
आईपीस। अब इसका जो सबनेट होगा 255.255.0.0
इसका मतलब क्या हुआ? फर्स्ट टू जो आपका
नंबर है वो सेम होगा एंड लास्ट के जो
नंबर्स हैं वो चेंज होते रहेंगे। यानी कि
इसमें क्योंकि IPपी एड्रेस ज्यादा होंगी,
वेरिएशंस ज्यादा होंगे, दो नंबर्स चेंज हो
रहे हैं। तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है कॉम्बिनेशन
ज्यादा हैं। तो 65534 या 535 जो IPपी
एड्रेस है जो आप कैलकुलेट कर लीजिएगा उतने
IPपी एड्रेसेस यहां पे आपको इसमें
मिलेंगे। एंड जो स्लश एट नोटेशन है इसका
सबनेट मास्क होता है 25500
यानी कि फर्स्ट नंबर ओनली सेम है 255 वाली
जो है वो फर्स्ट वाली डिजिट सब सेम रहेगी
ओनली लास्ट के तीनों चेंज होते रहेंगे और
इसमें टोटल होस्ट आते हैं 16 मिलियंस
होस्ट 16 मिलियन होस्ट यानी कि स्लैश एट
कहीं पे नेटवर्क आपको मिल जा रहा है किसी
भी बग बंटी प्रोग्राम में या कहीं कुछ आप
बग बंटी या कुछ ऐसा कर रहे हो एंड वहां पे
आपको स्लैश 8 टाइप का कोई एक सीआईडीआर मिल
जा रही है तो आपको बल्लेबले आपकी हो जानी
चाहिए क्योंकि उसमें आपको मिलेंगे 16
मिलियन होस्ट जब आप 16
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] मिलियन होस्ट
को स्कैन करोगे मास स्कैन या कोई भी एक
फास्ट स्कैनर से उतनी रिसोर्स होनी चाहिए
नेटवर्क कैपेबिलिटी होनी चाहिए तो आपको
कुछ ना कुछ तो इंटरेस्टिंग मिलेगा तो ये
बग बंटी हंटर्स के लिए भी काफी ज्यादा
यूज़फुल चीज होती है काफी ज्यादा
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज होती है अ जो ये आपको 16
मिलियन वाली चीज है राइट
इतना तो समझ में आ गया होगा। राइट?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब ये आपको
आसान लग रहा है ये सीआईडीआर सबनेट इजी लग
रहा है। आर यू फीलिंग इट लाइक फीलिंग
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] लाइक इट इजी ईजी
थिंग ऐसा कुछ लग रहा है आपको?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
इजी लग रहा है ना? अब ईजी एकदम लग रहा
होगा।
इजी लगना भी चाहिए यार। मैं मैं पढ़ाऊं और
इजी ना लगे तो फिर मेरा पढ़ाना बेकार है।
मैं [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सिखाऊं,
मैं ट्रेनिंग दूं, मैं अगर आपको पढ़ाऊं और
अगर आपको इजी ना लगे तो फिर मेरा पढ़ाना
बेकार है। चलिए
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सर आपने मेरा मेल शायद चेक नहीं किया। एक
एपीआई की लीक के बारे में बताया है। आपका
नाम क्या है ब्रदर? आप एक बार नाम बता
दीजिए अपना। मैं अगर हो सकता है मिस कर
गया होगा क्योंकि मेल्स आते रहते हैं तो
कई बार मिस हो जाता है तो आप प्लीज अपना
नाम बता दीजिए एक आई विल गो थ्रू दैट
बाद में भूल इसलिए जाते हैं क्योंकि
प्रैक्टिस में नहीं होती है ना इस वजह से
आई हैव टू रीवाच हां टेक डी आप एक बार
वापस देखिएगा आपको और ज्यादा अच्छे से
क्लियर होगा। ठीक है? चलिए
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ये तो थे IP
एड्रेस के कुछ बेसिक्स। अब आते हैं
वर्जनंस ऑफ़ आईपी एड्रेस। देखो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] दो वर्जन
होते हैं। मैंने पहले ही बोला था IP वर्जन
4, इंटरनेट प्रोटोकॉल वर्जन 4, IP वर्जन
सिक्स, इंटरनेट प्रोटोकॉल वर्जन सिक्स। IP
वर्जन 4 32 बिट का होता है। सॉरी
एक बैक कैसे होगा इसमें यार?
यह गलत बात है यार। अनडू का ऑप्शन ही नहीं
दिया यार।
अच्छा इरेजर है क्या?
हटो।
ठीक है। अब यहां पर देखते हैं इंटरनेट
प्रोटोकॉल वर्जन फोर। इंटरनेट प्रोटोकॉल
वर्जन सिक्स। ठीक है? एड्रेस साइज यहां पे
जो है IP एड्रेस की साइज 32 बिट होती है।
फोर वाले की मैंने पहले ही बताया। सिक्स
वाले की 128 बिट होती है। 128 बिट। ये
बहुत मैटर करेगा। अभी बताता हूं मैं। इसका
फॉर्मेट कुछ इस तरीके से होता है। चार
ऑक्टेट में डिवाइडेड होते हैं। बट IP
वर्जन सिक्स का फॉर्मेट हेक्साडेसिमल
फॉर्मेट होता है। इट्स नॉट काइंड ऑफ़
न्यूमेरिकल ओनली न्यूमेरिकल फॉर्मेट या
डेसिमल फॉर्मेट ये हेक्साडेसिमल होता है।
कुछ इस तरीके से 2001 डी बी ए जहां पे
नंबर्स एंड अल्फाबेट्स दोनों का ही अ
मिलीभगत होता है। निशार्ग निग क्या बात
है। वेलकम वेलकम।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
चलिए टोटल एड्रेसेस इसमें कितने थे IP
वर्जन 4 में आप इसमें यहां पर काउंट कर
सकते हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ये ऑलमोस्ट 42
करोड़ के आसपास आएगा ये। आई थिंक 42 करोड़
के आसपास आ रहा है ना ये? एक बार काउंट कर
लीजिए। इतने IP वर्जन फोर एड्रेसेस
अवेलेबल हैं। और इस पर्टिकुलर IP वर्जन
सिक्स में 3.4 * 10 टू दी पावर 38 IPपी
एड्रेसेस अवेलेबल हैं। जो कि जनरली जो है
वो वो
खत्म हो ही नहीं सकती। अभी इतनी इट्स
काइंड ऑफ़ अनलिमिटेड। ये इतनी आसानी से
खत्म नहीं होगी। अनलिमिटेड काइंड ऑफ़ थिंग
है। इसलिए IP वर्जन सिक्स को ल्च किया
गया। IP सिक्योरिटी। आईपीसी जो है वो
ऑप्शनल है। इसमें इसमें मैंडेटरी कर दिया
गया। एंड वहां पे वाइडली यूज्ड बट फेसिंग
एड्रेस एग्जॉस्ट एग्जॉशन जो मैंने आपको
बोला था कि ये एग्जॉस्ट कर रहा है।
एग्जॉशन हो रहा है उसकी। तो अब बहुत
ज्यादा यूज हो रही है ये। IP वर्जन 4 बहुत
ज्यादा हमेशा से यूज़ आती आ रही है।
इंटरनेट के इंसेप्शन से स्टार्टिंग से ही
यूज़ हो रही है। बट अब जो है इसके एड्रेसेस
खत्म हो रहे हैं। एंड
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां पे इसको
डिजाइन ही किया गया है IP वर्जन 4 को के
प्रॉब्लम को, इसके एग्जॉशन को, उसके
शॉर्टेज को, उसके लिमिटेशन को दूर करने के
लिए। तो IP वर्जन सिक्स को लाया गया। ठीक
है?
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ओके। अब आ जाते हैं IP एड्रेसेस के
क्लासेस के ऊपर। अब देखो IPपी एड्रेससेस
के टाइप्स भी होते हैं। अलग-अलग टाइप्स
होते हैं। प्राइवेट, पब्लिक, स्टैटिक,
डायनेमिक। फिर अगर हम ऑपरेशनल के ऊपर में
जाएं तो लाइक अ
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यू कैन एनी कास्ट होते हैं। मल्टी कास्ट
वगैरह होते हैं। एंड देयर आर
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट टाइप्स। ठीक है? हम अभी
उन सब चीज़ हम यहां पे क्लासेस को समझते
हैं। पहले आईपी एड्रेस के जो क्लासेस होते
हैं। ओके? सुमित पाल। ओके सुमित आई विल सी
द मेल। थैंक यू वेरी मच फॉर योर नेम।
हां जी बैकग्राउंड में अभी नॉइज़ आ रहा है
एंड मुझे
थोड़ा सा समझ नहीं आ रहा है कि ये जो माइक
है वो इसको ज्यादा कट क्यों नहीं कर रही
है बिकॉज़ ये तो कट कर देती है बट आई आई आई
एम नॉट अंडरस्टैंडिंग व्हाई इट्स नॉट
कटिंग कुछ होगा इशू होगा शायद पता नहीं बट
यस बैकग्राउंड में काफी ज्यादा नॉइज़ आ रहा
है बिल्कुल सही बोला आपने
उसके लिए एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी
क्लासेस जल्दी आ जाएंगी भाई चलो यहां पे
चार क्लासेस होते हैं आईपी एड्रेसेस के।
चार नहीं पांच क्लासेस होते हैं। पांच
इसको चार नहीं बोलेंगे। एक बेकार है। यूज़
का नहीं है। इसलिए मैंने चार बोल दिया था।
बट यहां पे जो है
होने वाला जल्दी होगा। निशार्क जल्दी
होगा।
ठीक है? चार पांच क्लासेस होते हैं। क्लास
ए, क्लास बी, क्लास सी, क्लास डी एंड
क्लास ई। ये चार पांच जो है वो क्लासेस
होते हैं आईपी एड्रेस के। अब इन क्लासेस
को समझते हैं। डिवाइडेड होते हैं पांच
क्लासेस में।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
क्लास ए अब इस पर्टिकुलर क्लास ए में जो
रेंज ऑफ आईपी एड्रेस होते हैं वो 10.0
से स्टार्ट हो के 126.255
2552 255.255 तक फॉल करते हैं। जितने भी
IP एड्रेस इस रेंज में आ रहे हैं वो क्लास
ए रेंज के IP एड्रेस कहलाते हैं। इसमें
नेटवर्क बिट्स एट होते हैं और होस्ट बिट
जो होते हैं 24 होते हैं। होस्ट का बिट
इसमें 24 होता है। याद रखिएगा जितनी
ज्यादा होस्ट के बिट होंगे जितनी ज्यादा
होस्ट के बिट होंगे उतनी क्या होती है अगर
होस्ट की बिट ज्यादा होंगी तो क्या होगा
भैया IP कम होंगी या ज्यादा होंगी बताइए
जल्दी जल्दी बताइए देखते हैं लेट्स सी अगर
होस्ट की बिट ज्यादा है
तो IP ज्यादा होंगी या कम होंगी
कम होंगी ऑब्वियस सी बात है
ज्यादा के
[हंसी]
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
अच्छा ठीक है। देखो यहां पे पहला पार्ट
नेटवर्क पार्ट होता है। दूसरा पार्ट होस्ट
पार्ट होता है। राइट? तो होस्ट पार्ट जैसे
हमने देखा था कि कैलकुलेशन जो होती है IP
एड्रेसेस की देखो अभी कंफ्यूज्ड हैं काफी
लोग कैलकुलेशन किस तरीके से होती है जो
टोटल नंबर ऑफ IPपी बिट्स होते हैं उसमें
से जो नोटेशन आपका जो भी आपका होता है
सीआईडीआर के अंदर में स्लश 24 या स्लैश
आपका 16 या जो भी उसको माइनस कर दिया जाता
है। तो जितने ज्यादा नंबर माइनस होंगे
उतनी आपकी कम आईपी जो है वो आपको मिलेगी।
जितनी ज्यादा नंबर माइनस होंगे उतनी कम
आईपी मिलेगी। समझ में आ रहा है आपको? आर
यू गेटिंग गाइस?
अच्छा एक सेकंड रुक जाइए। आई हैव टू आई
हैव टू स्टार्ट अ सेशन। जस्ट अ सेकंड
गाइस। मेरे को एक लिंक भेजना है। अह
एक सेकंड रुक जाइए।
तो जस्ट अ सेकंड मैं एक सेशन स्टार्ट सेंड
करके देन [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
आपको कंटिन्यू हम करते हैं।
हम हम
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
तब तक आप बताइए ज्यादा है कि कम है तब तक
आप बताइए फटाफट
एक्चुअली क्या होगा ज्यादा होगा कि कम
होगा तब तक आप बताओ
तब तक आईडिया लगे
दीदी को
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
हम
ओके गाइस जस्ट अ सेकंड तब तक आप आंसर
कीजिए मैं आंसर देखूंगा आप सभी के
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
हां [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] जी ओके सो
डन इधर
ओके
कुछ
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
हां जी तो मुझे कितने लोगों ने क्या बोला
है लेट्स सी कम ज्यादा क्या है एक बार देख
लेते हैं
ओके लेट्स सी व्हाट व्हाट पीपल आर सेइंग?
कम ज्यादा कम
[हंसी]
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ज्यादा होंगी। ज्यादा होंगी
चैट मिस ठीक है 25 में याद होंगे चलो ठीक
है चलो यहां पे जस्ट अ सेकंड
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
हम
ओके नाउ बैक बैक अगेन अगेन वापस आ गया मैं
एक सेशन एक्चुअली एक सेशन स्टार्ट कर रहा
था उसमें मैं
थोड़ा सा टाइम उधर चला गया अपना कोई बात
नहीं लेट्स स्टार्ट
अगेन
देखो
यहां पे होस्ट बिट का देखो यहां पे मतलब
समझो यहां पे यहां पे मतलब समझना ठीक है
यहां पे मतलब क्या है ये समझिएगा ठीक है
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है यहां मतलब समझिएगा देखो
जब रेंज यहां पे नेटवर्क बीट्स एट हो रहे
हैं यहां पे और होस्ट बिट्स जो हैं 24 हो
रहे हैं यहां पे। इसका मतलब है होस्ट को
जो होस्ट्स हैं आपके उसको ज्यादा बिट
प्रोवाइड की जा रही है। सिंपल मतलब होस्ट
को ज्यादा स्पेस मिल रहा है। और ये जो
क्लास ए के आईपी एड्रेसेस हैं ये आप
देखेंगे यहां पे कि लार्ज नेटवर्कक्स के
लिए यूज़ में लिया जाता है। जैसे कि
गवर्नमेंट ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस हो गए। इन सब
चीजें हो गए। इन सबके लिए यूज़ में लिया
जाता है। और इसमें भी हां देखो इसमें
इसमें भी जो 126 तक तो ठीक है। 127 जो
होता है वो रिजर्वड होता है लूप बैकक के
लिए। यह आप सबको शायद पता होना चाहिए लूप
बैकक एड्रेस क्या होती है? लूप बैकक एक
लोकल IPपी एड्रेस हो गया। एक लोकल IPपी
एड्रेस हो गया जो हर सिस्टम को फिक्स्ड
असाइन होती है। एंड वो एड्रेस क्या होता
है पता है आपको? वो एड्रेस क्या हो जाता
है? वो एड्रेस होता है 127
0.01
लोकल होस्ट की IP यह सभी डिवाइसेस को आपको
ये लोकल होस्ट की आईपी सेम होती है। अब
मैं मेरी भी डिवाइस की अगर मैं आपको
सीएमडी ओपन करके दिखाऊं एंड मैं यहां पे
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] IP कॉन्फ़िग
डालूं
तो यहां पे मुझे एक लूप बैकक एड्रेस
मिलेगा ही मिलेगा। मैं आपको
अगर यहां पे मुझे दिखता है लूपक तो मैं
दिखा देता हूं। इफ आई कैन से द लूप बैकक
इसमें शायद नहीं आएगा लूप बैकक
ओके आईपी कॉन्फ्ल ऑल पे कर लेते हैं इसमें
देख लेते हैं सारे अप्टर्स इसमें आ जाएंगे
इसमें हमारा लूप बैकक वाला भी डिटेक्ट हो
आ ही जाएगा आ जाना चाहिए मेरे ख्याल से हम
हम
ओके इसमें हमारा लोकल लोकल होस्ट वाला वो
वाला अभी डिटेक्ट नहीं हो रहा है बट आप
किसी भी सिस्टम सिस्टम में आप इस बात को
एकदम से समझ के चलिए कि एक ऐसी एड्रेस
होती है, एक ऐसी IPपी एड्रेस होती है
जिसको हम लूप बैकक एड्रेस बोलते हैं जो
आपके लोकल होस्ट का एड्रेस होता है। आपको
यहां दिखे ना दिखे उससे मतलब नहीं है। वो
आपका बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट होता है। तो कोई भी आप
एप्लीकेशन कोई भी आप ऐसी सर्विस जो आप
लोकल होस्ट पे चलाएंगे उसको आप उस IP
एड्रेस पे एक्सेस कर सकते हैं जो कि क्या
है आपका 127.0.0.1
तो यहां पे अभी तो मेरे सारे अप्टर्स के
आईपीस और ये सब चीजें दिख रही है। लूपक
एड्रेस का यहां पे अभी कहीं पे दिख नहीं
रहा वो। बट इसका मतलब ये नहीं है कि नहीं
होता है। आपको हर पर्टिकुलर डिवाइस का एक
लूप बैकक एड्रेस जो होता है वो फिक्स होता
है। एंड दैट इज 127
0.0.1
ये हमेशा याद रखिएगा। ठीक है? हां, जैसे
कि आपका अबवशूट को आप कॉन्फ़िगर कीजिए या
कुछ भी आप किसी भी तरह का कोई एप्लीकेशन
ज़म सर्वर को आप कफ़िगर कीजिए या आप खुद की
वेबसाइट को लोकल होस्ट पे आप रखिए, उसको
एक्सेस कीजिए, टेस्ट कीजिए, डीबग कीजिए।
वो सब 127.0.1
पे होता है। ये फंडा यहीं पे है आपका कि
आपका जो रेंज है ये रेंज वन से 26 तक का
है। 27 जो है लूप बैकक के लिए फिक्स है।
क्लास बी जो आपकी होती है जो आईपी क्लासेस
में बी जो होता है क्लास बी वो होता है
शुरू। 128 से 127 इधर रह गया। 128 से 191
तक का आपका क्लास बी रेंज होता है। इसमें
आपको नेटवर्क बिट 16 एंड होस्टिट 16 इक्वल
मिलते हैं। मीडियम साइज नेटवर्क्स के लिए
यूज़ में होते हैं। जैसे कॉलेजेस,
यूनिवर्सिटीज वगैरह मोस्टली इस आईपी रेंज
को यूज़ करती है। क्लास सी जो रेंज है वो
192 से लेके 223 तक होता है क्लास सी का
रेंज। एंड इसमें नेटवर्क बिग 24 होश बिट 8
होते हैं। ये स्मॉल नेटवर्क्स होते हैं।
छोटे नेटवर्क्स होते हैं क्योंकि होस्टिट
यहां पे ऑब्वियस सी बात है। एंड यहां पे
एग्जांपल होम एंड स्मॉल बिनेसेस जो हैं
उसमें यूज़ में लिए जाते हैं। ये क्लास सी
की है। क्लास डी जो रेंज है वो 2 4 से
स्टार्ट हो के 2 39 तक आपकी जाती है। ये
डी रेंज की है। अब इसको थोड़ा सा याद ही
करना पड़ेगा। मेमोराइज करना पड़ेगा। ये
रटने वाली चीजें हैं। इसमें ज्यादा दिमाग
लगा नहीं सकते आप। टाइम के साथ प्रैक्टिस
के साथ-साथ बहुत लोगों के दिमाग में छप
जाता है। ये कई लोग याद नहीं कर पाते तो
कोई टेंशन नहीं है। इतना आजकल वो सोचना
नहीं है। एक बार इंटरनेट पर सर्च करोगे
मिल जाएगा तुम्हें। ठीक है? तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] एकदम बेफिक्र
रहिएगा। इसको यूज़ किया जाता है मल्टीकास्ट
कम्युनिकेशन के लिए। मैंने मतलब
मल्टीकास्ट कम्युनिकेशन जो होती है उसके
लिए यूज़ में लिया जाता है। जैसे अगर कोई
मल्टीपल कम्युनिकेशन मल्टीपल स्ट्रीम
कम्युनिकेशन होती है या मल्टीपल चीजें एक
बार कम्युनिकेट कर पा रहे हैं आप नेटवर्क
के अंदर सॉकेट के थ्रू तो उसके थ्रू आप
उसके लिए ये चीज यूज़ में आती है। वीडियो
स्ट्रीमिंग प्लेटफॉर्म्स या जो भी चीजें
वीडियो स्ट्रीमिंग अगर हो रही है
प्लेटफार्म जो है वो जनरली क्लास डी आईपी
एड्रेस से डील करती है। लास्ट है हमारा
क्लास ई का IPपी एड्रेस जो कि 240 से 255
तक आपका रेंज करता है। इसको जनरली जो है
यूज़ नॉर्मली नहीं कहीं पे किया जाता है।
पब्लिक नेटवर्किंग में तो यूज़ ऑलमोस्ट
नहीं किया जाता है। ये एक्सपेरिमेंट एंड
रिसर्च के लिए रखा जाता है कि जब मतलब कोई
एक्सपेरिमेंट हो रही है रिसर्च हो रहा है
तो उसमें ये आईपी एड्रेससेस को यूटिलाइज़
किया जाता है। तो ये पांच क्लासेस हैं ए
बी सी डी ई। इनकी एक रेंज है वन से 126
फिर 128 से 191 192 से 223 से 224 से 239
तक एंड 240 से 255 तक आपका ये पूरा रेंज
होता है। तो ये क्लासेस ऑफ आईपी एड्रेस हो
गए। अब इसी में टाइप्स ऑफ आईपी एड्रेससेस
भी होते हैं। देखो पहले हमने वर्जनंस ऑफ़
आईपी एड्रेसेस देखा फोर सिक्स। फिर हमने
क्लास देखा ए बी सी डी। अब हम देख रहे हैं
यहां पे टाइप्स ऑफ आईपी एड्रेसेस। अब देखो
टाइप्स में चार मेन टाइप्स मैंने यहां पे
नोटिस नोट किया हुआ है। एक पब्लिक, एक
प्राइवेट, एक स्टैटिक, एक डायनेमिक। अब ये
नॉर्मल सा चीज है। इसको आप एक्सप्लोर
कीजिएगा खुद से। बहुत नॉर्मल सी चीज है।
कोई बड़ी चीज नहीं है। पब्लिक आईपी जो
होती है, यह पब्लिकली असाइन आईपी आपको जो
होती है, जैसे आपका इंटरनेट सर्विस
प्रोवाइडर है, आपको एक आईपी असाइन कर रहा
है या कोई भी एक वैन IPपी है, वाइड एरिया
नेटवर्क आईपी है वो पब्लिक आईपी हो जाती
है। प्राइवेट प्राइवेट आईपी जो आपके एक
डिवाइस को डिनोट करती है। जैसे आपके जैसे
मैं यहां पे सीएमडी जैसे मैंने सीएमडी ओपन
किया था ना मैंने यहां पे आईपी कॉन्फ़िग
डाला था। राइट? तो यहां पे मेरे को ये IP
मिल रही है 18268.232.1
हो गया या फिर मेरे डिवाइस का भी अप्टर का
है 1926.1.4
जो ये मेरा प्राइवेट IPपी है। तो दिस इज़
प्राइवेट IPपी है। पब्लिक IPपी की बात
करें तो व्हाट इज़ माय IPपी एड्रेस पे
जाएंगे आप तो आपको वहां पे पब्लिक आईपी
दिख जाएगा आपका। व्हाट इज़ माय IP
एड्रेस.com ये जो वेबसाइट है इस पे जब आप
जाएंगे तो आपको आपकी पब्लिक आईपी दिख
जाएगी आईएसपी वाली। अब एक होती है स्टैटिक
आईपी। ये स्टैटिक आईपी कुछ नहीं होता। यह
एक इनवैलिड आईपी होता है। इसको हम वैलिड
नहीं बोल सकते हैं। यह एक नॉर्मल सी जो
आईपी आपकी होती है ना जो जो भी आपकी
प्राइवेट आईपी होती है उसी को स्टैटिक बना
दिया। एक स्टैटिक वे में यूज़ कर लिया
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन करके कि हम अब जैसे मेरे पास
एक IP है 1921 168.1.4
अब मैंने उसी को स्टैटिकली मैनुअली असाइन
कर दिया मेरे सिस्टम को। तो इसका मतलब यह
हुआ कि मेरे सिस्टम को हमेशा 19268.14
ही मिलेगी IP। कोई और IP नहीं मिलेगी। तो
यह एक फिक्स्ड आईपी करना हो जाता है और
कुछ भी स्टैटिक आईपी नहीं होता है। यह
आईपी वैलिड कंसीडर भी नहीं होता है। दिस
इज़ इनवैलिड और आईपी
जो होते हैं कई बार आईपीस दो आईपीस के बीच
में इशूज़ भी होते हैं। आपके कई बार दोनों
आईपीस के बीच का प्रॉब्लम इशूज़ आ जाता है
इसके कारण से कई बार कि आपने एक फिक्स कर
दिया है। दूसरा IP भी अह किसी सिस्टम को
कि सेम IPपी अगर असाइन होने की कोशिश हो
रही है तो वहां पे थोड़ी सी इशू आ जाती
है। कई बार ऐसा होता है। बट देखो ऐसा ऐसा
नहीं है कि ये नॉर्मल केस है। ये कभी रेयर
केस में हो गया। ऐसे नॉर्मली डीएससीपी भी
करता है आपका तब भी ऐसा केस आ जाता है। इस
तरीके की चीज़ आ जाती है। बट यहां पे
स्टैटिक का मतलब है एक फिक्स्ड आईपी। आपकी
जो कोई एक प्राइवेट आईपी उसको फिक्स कर
देना एक मशीन के लिए, एक कंप्यूटर के लिए,
एक लैपटॉप के लिए, एक मोबाइल के लिए। तो
ये एक नॉर्मल चीज है। अब यहां पे डायनेमिक
आईपी। अभी डायनेमिक आईपी जो होती है ये
आपकी जैसे पब्लिक आईपी है ना उसी में एक
आपकी पब्लिक आईपी में भी ना एक स्टैटिक
आईपी होती है और एक डायनेमिक होती है। तो
अब पब्लिक में मैं प्राइवेट की बात नहीं
कर रहा। अब वो जो पब्लिक आईपी में स्टैटिक
आईपी होती है ना वो होती है महंगी
कॉस्टली। तो आपका आईएसपी जनरली डायनेमिक
आईपी ही असाइन करता है आपको। जैसे अगर
मेरे इस मैं अभी Airtel का Airtel का
फाइबर यूज़ कर रहा हूं। राइट? आप लोग हो
सकता है आप लोग भी Airtel Fiverr यूज़ करते
हैं या फिर हो सकता है कि आप लोग Jio
Fiverr यूज़ करते होंगे या Air Fiverr यूज़
करते होंगे। उसमें IPपी एड्रेस जो आपको
मिलती है आईएसपी के द्वारा वो जनरली क्या
होता है ना डायनेमिक होता है लिटरली
क्योंकि स्टैटिक IPपी एड्रेस महंगी होती
है। कॉस्टली होती है। अगर आप स्टैटिक आईपी
वाले कोई प्लान लेते हैं इंटरनेट का तो वो
आपको महंगा पड़ता है। उसके आपको अलग से
एक्स्ट्रा चार्ज देने पड़ते हैं क्योंकि
वो महंगा अलॉट ही होता है। तो आपको
डायनेमिक दिया जाता है। यानी कि आपकी जो
पब्लिक आईपी भी है ना वो जब डायनेमिक
असाइन होगी तो एक टाइम के बाद जैसे हो
सकता है एक सप्ताह के बाद या 1 महीने के
बाद वो चेंज हो जाती है। ऑटोमेटिकली चेंज
हो जाएगी। ये आप नोटिस करके देखना ऐसा
होता है डायनेमिक जब वो असाइन होगा। लेकिन
अगर आपको आईएसपी ने स्टैटिक आईपी दिया
आपके प्लान के साथ तो वो हमेशा लाइफ टाइम
जब तक आपके पास वो इंटरनेट कनेक्शन है तब
तक वो फिक्स्ड आईपी रहेगी। जनरली स्टैटिक
आईपीस ज्यादा बेटर होते हैं। जब आप पोर्ट
फॉरवर्डिंग वगैरह की सर्विज यूज़ करते हैं
तो आपके लिए वो कांस्टेंट आईपी होता है।
बट डायनेमिक आईपी में वो चेंज हो जाता है
कुछ टाइम के बाद। तो अगर आपने कोई पोर्ट
फॉरवर्डिंग रूल क्रिएट करा है कुछ ऐसा तो
बार-बार आपको उसमें जा के आईपी चेंज करनी
पड़ती है। नहीं तो आपका वो काम नहीं
करेगा। तो ये एक बेनिफिट है स्टैटिक आईपी
का। दैट्स इट। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
हां, डायनेमिक आईपी चेंज होता है। बिल्कुल
वही मैंने बोला।
ठीक है? ये तो समझ में आ गया होगा आपको।
चलिए अब एज अ एसओसी पर्सपेक्टिव अगर देखें
तो प्राइवेट आईपी टाइप अगर है तो वो
इंटरनल ट्रैफिक माना जाएगा और पब्लिक आईपी
टाइप है तो वो एक्सटर्नल ट्रैफिक माना
जाएगा। उसको एक्सटर्नल कनेक्शन हम
मानेंगे। यानी कि प्राइवेट आईपी को हम
इंटरनल ट्रैफिक मानेंगे। एंड पब्लिक आईपी
अगर होगी तो वो एक्सटर्नल कनेक्शन है। तो
अगर एसओसी अगर आप L1 है तो कहीं पे
प्राइवेट आईपी देख रहे हैं आप तो आप उसको
समझिए कि वो इंटरनल आईपी का पार्ट है।
इंटरनल सबनेट का पार्ट है। इंटरनल आईपी
पूल का पार्ट है। एंड अगर पब्लिक आईपी आप
देख रहे हैं कहीं पे तो समझ लीजिए
एक्सटर्नल नेटवर्क का पार्ट है। ठीक है?
जैसे कि अगर सोर्स आपका कुछ ये है
डेस्टिनेशन आपके कुछ है। ये है तो यानी कि
इंटरनल नेटवर्क से एक्सटर्नल नेटवर्क की
कम्युनिकेशन हो रही है। एज अ एसओसी आपका
ये पर्सपेक्टिव होना चाहिए।
ठीक है? चलिए। अब आ जाते हैं हमारे मैक
एड्रेस पे कि भैया यह मैक एड्रेस क्या
होता है? देखो IPपी एड्रेस का कांसेप्ट और
IP एड्रेस में अभी तक जो चीजें मैंने बताई
आपको वो सारी चीजें क्लियर हो गई आपकी?
बताइए वो [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सारी चीजें क्लियर हो गई? लेट मी नो।
लेट मी नो गाइस। लेट मी नोस्ट। हरी अप
एकदम क्लियर क्या बात है मजे में क्लियर
हुआ ना मजेमजे में मजा आया ना
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
हां कंपनीज़ स्टैटिक आईपी ही प्रेफर करती
है बिल्कुल सही बात है स्टैटिक आईपी दे
प्रेफर कंपनी जितने भी कंपनी होती है वह
स्टैटिक आईपी प्रेफर करती है हां जी यही
तो दिक्कत है
लाइक नहीं ठोका। आज आज बहुत कम लोगों ने
लाइक ठोका है। कोई बात नहीं चलता है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके। अब आते हैं मैक एड्रेस पे। देखो मैक
एड्रेस क्या होता है? मैक एड्रेस
देखो ये नाम मैक एड्रेस है। इसका फुल
फॉर्म अजीब है। मीडिया एक्सेस कंट्रोल।
मीडिया एक्सेस कंट्रोल। इसका फुल फॉर्म
अजीब है। मुझे आज तक इसका फुल फॉर्म और
इसके काम में कोई कनेक्शन नहीं समझ में
आया। मैक का जो फुल फॉर्म है मीडिया
एक्सेस कंट्रोल और इसका जो काम है दोनों
में कोई कॉम्बिनेशन दोनों में कोई समानता
नहीं है यार दोनों अलग ही है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] मैक एड्रेस
इज अ हार्डवेयर लेवल यूनिक आइडेंटिफायर।
मैक एड्रेस एक हार्डवेयर लेवल का एक यूनिक
आइडेंटिफायर होता है। जैसे था ना आईपी
यूनिक आइडेंटिफायर वैसे ही मैक जो है
हमारे वो
वो क्या होते हैं? वो हार्डवेयर के यूनिक
आइडेंटिफायर होते हैं। फिजिकल एड्रेस होते
हैं। फिजिकल एड्रेस किसका? जैसे मेरा
लैपटॉप है तो मैक एड्रेसेस का। मेरा फोन
है मैक एड्रेसेस का। जो भी डिवाइसेस है ना
उनका एड्रेस मैक एड्रेस होता है। डिवाइसेस
वो हार्डवेयर का उस पर्टिकुलर भीतर के
उसका नहीं एक सॉफ्टवेयर का नहीं अंदर का
चीज वो हार्डवेयर का ही जो एड्रेस है वही
मैक एड्रेस है। और
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] कुछ इस तरीके
से ये डिनोट किए जाते हैं। अगेन
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] स्ट्रक्चर
क्या होता है? 48 बिट का एड्रेस होता है।
यह हैक्स फॉर्मेट में लिखा होता है। 48
बिट का एड्रेस होता है। IP 32 बिट का IP
वर्जन 4 32 बिट्स, IP वर्जन सिक्स 128 बिट
एंड मैक एड्रेस 48 बिट का एड्रेस होता है।
ये सब चीजें कॉमन चीज़ हैं। इसको याद
रखिएगा। कई बार इंटरव्यूज वगैरह में भी
पूछ दिया जाता है।
कि मैक एड्रेस इज़ ऑफ़ हाउ मेनी बिट्स
एड्रेस।
ठीक है? हां, चेंज कर सकते हैं टेंपरेरी?
बिल्कुल।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
इसके दो पार्ट होते हैं। मैक एड्रेस के भी
दो पार्ट होते हैं। फर्स्ट हाफ आपका
मैन्युफैक्चरर
के बारे में बताता है। सेकंड हाफ आपका
डिवाइस की आईडी के बारे में बताता है। ठीक
है? फर्स्ट हाफ मैन्युफैक्चरर सेकंड हाफ
डिवाइस की आईडी। इसको हम ऐसे समझ लेते
हैं। देखिए मीडिया एक्सेस कंट्रोल एड्रेस
जब भी मैं फुल फॉर्म इसका देखता हूं मुझे
हंसी आती है। पता नहीं क्यों हंसी आती है।
मुझे लगता है कि ये क्या इसका क्यों मतलब
फुल फॉर्म क्यों रखा है ये? मीडिया एक्सेस
कंट्रोल कौन सी मीडिया एक्सेस? डिवाइस
एक्सेस कंट्रोल लिख देते कुछ और लिख देते
डीएससी लिख देते मीडिया एक्सेस क्या होता
है तो मीडिया एक्सेस कंट्रोल भैया हमारे
नाम है इसके छह ऑक्टेट होते हैं। जैसे
आईपी एड्रेस में चार थे ना यहां पे छह
आपके होते हैं। तो फर्स्ट जो थ्री है आपका
ये ऑर्गेनाइजेशनली यूनिक आइडेंटिफायर होता
है। ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस के तरफ से ये नंबर
असाइन किए जाते हैं। इन फ़
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] थ्री नंबर से
पता चलता है कि जो यह डिवाइस है पर्टिकुलर
इसका जो मैक एड्रेस असाइन हुआ है वह किस
कंपनी के तरफ़ से असाइन हुआ है। कौन सी
कंपनी ने उसको असाइन करा है। ठीक है? यह
आइडेंटिफायर होते हैं। एंड जो लास्ट का
तीन होता है वो नेटवर्क इंटरफेस कंट्रोलर
स्पेसिफिक होते हैं। एनआईसी स्पेसिफिक जो
आपका एनआईसी होता है नेटवर्क इंटरफेस
कार्ड या नेटवर्क इंटरफेस कंट्रोलर उसकी
वो एक आईडी होती है। यानी कि आपकी जो
डिवाइस आईडी होती है उसकी आईडी होती है।
बस यह लास्ट वाला और यह होती है जिस कंपनी
ने इसको असाइन किया है इस मैक एड्रेस जिस
कंपनी से बिलोंग करती है वो फर्स्ट वाली
हमारी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को दिखाता है। अब मैं
अगर Google करें हम
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
मैक
मैक एड्रेस कोड्स ऐसे कुछ ऐसे हम करें तो
यहां पे आपको मिल जाएगा यहां पे मैक
एड्रेस कोड्स डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट के जैसे
Sisco का आपका जो होता है वो CC46 DD6
या0000
ओ ओ ओ ओ ओ सी ये हो गया आपका Google का
3C5 5A V4 हेवलेट पैकेट यानी HP का आपका
3C D9 2B ज़ेरॉक्स ऐसे करके ये अलग-अलग
मैन्युफैक्चरर के एक फिक्स्ड जो होते हैं
फर्स्ट थ्री नंबर जो होते हैं आपके वो
होते हैं जो यहां पे मैक एड्रेस का पहला
तीन डिनोट करता है। तो पहला तीन जो अगर
आपको ये दिख रहा है इससे आपको पता चल
जाएगा एग्जैक्टली कि ये पर्टिकुलर डिवाइस
का जो मैक एड्रेस है वो किसने असाइन करा
है? किस कंपनी ने असाइन करा है ये चीज़। बस
इससे आपको पता चल जाएगा। अब जैसे कि मैं
यहां पे सीएमडी में चलता हूं। मैक एड्रेस
चलो मैं मैक एड्रेस नहीं दिखाऊंगा। इसको
छोड़ देते हैं। आप सीएमडी में जाइएगा। मैक
एड्रेस अपना देख लीजिएगा। एंड उसका फर्स्ट
थ्री डिजिट जो है Google पे सर्च कर
लीजिएगा कि एक्सैक्टली वो किस
मैन्युफैक्चर की तरफ से मतलब कौन सी कंपनी
ने उसको असाइन करा है। ये समझ में आ गया
होगा। ठीक है? या वेलकम मोहम्मद यासीन।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? चलिए [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब मैक एड्रेस के बारे में आप समझ गए
होंगे। बहुत ज्यादा इसमें आपको जाना नहीं
है। बस जान लीजिए कि यह एक 48 बिट का
एड्रेस है। हेक्स फॉर्म में लिखा होता है।
फर्स्ट हाफ मैन्युफैक्चर के बारे में
बताता है। सेकंड ऐप जो है वो आपके किसके
बारे में? डिवाइस की आईडी यानी एनआईसी की
आईडी के बारे में। एनआईसी नेटवर्क इंटरफेस
कार्ड या कंट्रोलर के बारे में बताता है।
मैक एड्रेस में ही एक कांसेप्ट होता है
एआरपी जिसको हम बोलते हैं एड्रेस
रेज़ोल्यूशन प्रोटोकॉल। अब ये इतना ये
इसलिए इंपॉर्टेंट है एआरपी क्या करता है?
IP को मैप पे मैप करता है। जैसे आपका
डीएनएस था ना डोमेन नेम सिस्टम जो डोमेन
को IP पे मैप करता था। एक डोमेन को IP पे
क्योंकि ब्राउज़र कोई इन सबको IP समझ में
आती है। डोमेनवन तो कुछ पता नहीं है। उसी
तरीके से एआरपी का काम है IP को मैप पे
मॉन मैप कर देना। इसका मतलब एआरपी का काम
क्या है? वो क्या है? एआरपी एड्रेस लीजन
प्रोटोकॉल वो क्या पूछताछ करती है नेटवर्क
के अंदर में। नेटवर्क के अंदर में क्या
करेगा? वह एक IP के बारे में पता लगाएगा
कि जैसे कोई IP है 192 168.1 अब एआरपी काम
है 192 168.1 आईपी के इन्वेस्टिगेशन करना।
अरे भैया ये आईपी किसकी है?
मतलब ये आईपी किसकी है? ये आईपी कौन किसकी
आईपी है भाई? ये तो एक बंदा बोलेगा ये
मेरी आईपी है यार। मैं हूं मैं हूं मैं
हूं। अरे मैं हूं। तो वो पूछेगा अच्छा तू
है। ठीक है। बता भाई अब तेरी मैक एड्रेस
क्या है? तू बता कि मैक एड्रेस क्या है?
तो अब वो डिवाइस बताएगा कि मेरा मैक
एड्रेस ये है। यानी कि ये IP एड्रेसेस का
मैक एड्रेस लेके उसकी एक एआरपी कैश टेबल
में एंट्री कर देता है। एंड जब वो एआरपी
कैश टेबल बन जाती है तो उसी के बेसिस पे
डिवाइस के अंदर कम्युनिकेशंस होती हैं। जो
ब्रॉडकास्टिंग और कम्युनिकेशन ये सब होती
है दो डिवाइसेस के बीच में वो इसी बेसिस
पे होती है। क्योंकि हमारा IP एड्रेस तो
हमें पता है बट मैक एड्रेस नहीं पता कि IP
किस मैक से एसोसिएटेड है। तो ये एआरपी
पूछता है भैया ये IP किसकी आईपी किसकी है?
तो मैक वो बोलता है अरे भैया मेरी है। तो
बता तो मैक एड्रेस तेरी क्या है भाई? तो
बताते हैं मेरी मैक एड्रेस ये है। तो बस
हो गया। तो पता चल जाता है दोनों IP और
मैक का मिलन हो जाता है। दोनों एक दूसरे
के लिए जुड़ जाते हैं। एक दूसरे के साथ
जुड़ जाते हैं हमेशा के लिए। एंड इस तरीके
से एक कम्युनिकेशन स्टार्ट हो जाती है।
राइट? ये समझ में आ गया होगा। अब यहां पे
आते हैं मैक एड्रेस और IP एड्रेस के बीच
की एक झलक देखते हैं। एक डिफरेंशिएशन
देखते हैं कि इन दोनों के बीच का डिफरेंस
क्या है? उसको थोड़ा सा हम समझने की कोशिश
करते हैं। ओके लेट्स
थोड़ा सा इसको ज़ूम करते हैं।
इतना आसान तो नहीं है।
चलो इस तरह से आपको आई थिंक यहां पे दिख
तो रहा होगा शायद। आपको दिख रहा है ये
टेबल दिख रही। आपको जो ये
डिफरेंस है वो दिख रहा है आप लोगों को
दोनों में आप पढ़ पा रहे हैं
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
देख पा रहे हैं आप
क्या बात है एसटी हैकर
जल्दी होगा भाई। जल्दी होगा। अब क्लास ओवर
ही होने वाली है। रीडेबल है। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] देखो IPपी
एड्रेस वर्सेस मैक एड्रेस देखें तो मैक
एड्रेस क्या होता है? अ यूनिक आइडेंटिफायर
असाइन टू अ नेटवर्क इंटरफेस कंट्रोलर।
एनआईसी जो है एनआईसी को असाइन एक यूनिक
आइडेंटिफायर होता है। IPपी एड्रेस क्या हो
जाता है? आपके नेटवर्क में जो डिवाइसेस
हैं उनको असाइन एक एड्रेस होता है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यह मीडिया एक्सेस कंट्रोल है। यह इंटरनेट
प्रोटोकॉल एड्रेस है। इसको हम मैक एड्रेस
को ही हम फिजिकल एड्रेस या हार्डवेयर
एड्रेस या इथरनेट एड्रेस भी बोलते हैं।
यानी मैक एड्रेस को हम फिजिकल एड्रेस भी
बोलते हैं। हार्डवेयर एड्रेस भी बोलते
हैं, इथर एड्रेस भी बोलते हैं। एंड IPपी
एड्रेस को हम लॉजिकल एड्रेस भी बोलते हैं।
नेटवर्क और इंटरनेट एड्रेस भी बोलते हैं।
यानी नेटवर्क एड एड्रेस कोई बोले, इंटरनेट
एड्रेस कोई बोले, लॉजिकल एड्रेस बोले तो
समझ जाना IP एड्रेस ही है। ये हेल्प करता
है मैक एड्रेस आपका टू यूनिकली आइडेंटिफाई
द डिवाइस और IPपी एड्रेस हेल्प करता है टू
आइडेंटिफाई द कनेक्शन ऑफ अ डिवाइस ऑन द
इंटरनेट। मतलब कौन-कौन सी डिवाइसेस
कनेक्टेड है उसका पता लगाने के लिए ये IP
बताया जाता है। मतलब वो पर्टिकुलर डिवाइस
को असाइन हुआ है। यह
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] असाइन किया
जाता है मैन्युफैक्चर के द्वारा। मैक
एड्रेस जो है जो एनआईसी जो नेटवर्क
इंटरफ़ेस कार्ड आपका लगा होता है बेसिकली
मतलब आप जिससे अपना इंटरनेट इथ केबल वगैरह
लगा पाते हैं वाई-फाई वगैरह जनरली यूज़ कर
पाते हैं तो वो जो मैन्युफैक्चरर है उसके
द्वारा असाइन किया जाता है आपका मैक
एड्रेस और [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
आपका जो IPपी एड्रेस है वो आईएसपी के
द्वारा असाइन किया जाता है आईएसपी ठीक है
हां यार यह ज़ूम हो रही है बट यह
क्या हो रहा है कि पीपीटी का यह ज़ूम नहीं
हो रहा। यह नहीं ज़ूम हो रहा। वैसे ज़ूम हो
रहा है बस। [हंसी]
ठीक है? तो मैक एड्रेस को असाइन किया जाता
है मैन्युफैक्चरर के द्वारा। जो आपके
नेटवर्क इंटरफ़ेस कार्ड का जो
मैन्युफैक्चरर है एनआईसी का उसका जो
मैन्युफैक्चर है वो असाइन करता है। IP
एड्रेस को असाइन किया जाता है आईएसपी के
द्वारा। इंटरनेट सर्विस प्रोवाइडर आपके
जैसे हो जैसे Airtel हो गया, Jio हो गया,
Voda हो गया। जिसके भी आप इंटरनेट यूज़ कर
रहे हैं वो आपका IPपी एड्रेस असाइन करते
हैं। मैक एड्रेस को चेंज नहीं किया जा
सकता है। एक नॉर्मल अगर तरीके से बात करें
तो IPपी एड्रेस को चेंज किया जा सकता है।
नॉर्मल तरीके से बात करें तो यही है।
एबनॉर्मल तरीके से हैकर हैकर व्यू से हम
बात करें हैकर व्यू देखें तो उस केस में
IP एड्रेस भी चेंज होती ही होती है। IP
एड्रेस स्पूफ होती है। मैक एड्रेस भी चेंज
होता है। स्पूफ होता है। हां। अब वो
टेंपरेरी होता है। दैट इज़ द अनदर फैक्ट कि
आप मैक एड्रेस को टेंपरेली स्पूफ कर सकते
हैं, चेंज कर सकते हैं। IPपी एड्रेस को आप
बिल्कुल कुछ भी IPपी एड्रेस के साथ आप कुछ
भी कर सकते हैं। देयर आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स
दैट कैन बी डन विद द आईपी एड्रेस। क्योंकि
हम यहां ऑफेंसिव नहीं सीख रहे हैं, पढ़ रहे
हैं। तो, हम उस पे अभी नहीं जा रहे हैं।
ओनली डिफेंसिव थिंग्स वी आर गोइंग टू
लर्न। ये 48 बिट्स का होता है। यानी 6
बाइट लॉन्ग होता है। IP वर्जन 4 32 बिट
एंड 6 128 बिट 128 बिट ऑलरेडी डील हमने कर
लिया इस चीज को। अब मैक एड्रेस जो है वो
ओएसi के डेटा लिंक लेयर में काम करता है
और जो आपका IP एड्रेस है वो नेटवर्क लेयर
में काम करता है। तो मैक एड्रेस डेटा लिंक
लेयर में ऑपरेट होती है और आपका जो IP
एड्रेस है वो नेटवर्क लेयर में ऑपरेट करता
है। ठीक है? या मैक एड्रेस परमानेंट होता
है बट उसको टेंपरेरी चेंज किया जा सकता
है। कि आपको ये आई होप कि डिफरेंसेस भी
समझ में आ गए होंगे मैक एड्रेस और IP
एड्रेस के बीच की। अब रियल एसोसिएट
सिनेरियो की हम बात करें यहां पे
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तो अगर बहुत
सारे मल्टीपल डिवाइसेस कुछ इस तरीके की
नोटेशंस शो कर रहे हैं कि मल्टीपल
डिवाइसेस शो इस तरह का कोई अगर अलर्ट आ
रहा है मल्टीपल डिवाइसेस शोइंग सेम मैक
एड्रेस। कि मल्टीपल डिवाइसेस सेम मैकड शो
करने लग रहे हैं। तो इसका मतलब समझ जाइए
कि यह एआरपी स्पोफिंग या मैन इन द मिडिल
अटैक का एक केस है। एज एन एसओसी एल1 आपको
ये चीज समझ में आनी चाहिए। एज अ एसोसल वन
आपको ये चीज क्लियर होना चाहिए कि जब इस
तरह की कोई सिचुएशन आई तो समझिए कि वो
एआरपी अटैक है एआरपी से रिलेटेड। क्योंकि
एआरपी का ही काम है आईपी को मैप पे मैप
करना। अगर वह गलत हो गया कोई और अटैकर आके
गलत मैप गलत आईपी को गलत मैक पर मैप कर दे
रहा है। इसका मतलब है कि बहुत सारे
डिवाइसेस को सेम मैक एड्रेसेस मिल जाएंगी
और वो एक मैक स्पोफिंग का भी केस है।
एआरपी स्पोफिंग का केस है। मैन इन द मिडिल
अटैक इसका भी केस है। जैसे बहुत सारे
नेटवर्क जो होते हैं जब आप
कई ऐसे वाई-फाई नेटवर्क होते हैं जहां पे
मैक एड्रेस की सिक्योरिटी लगी रहती है।
मैक बेस्ड फ़्टरिंग लगी होती है। यानी कि
उसमें ऐसा होता है कि कुछ सिलेक्टेड मैक
एड्रेस को डाल दिया जाता है फ़िल्टर में।
वही मैक एड्रेस वाले सिस्टम कनेक्ट कर
सकते हैं उस वाई-फाई नेटवर्क से। एक
सिक्योरिटी है। अगर बाय चांस आपको उस
पर्टिकुलर नेटवर्क के अंदर की किसी एक
डिवाइस की मैक एड्रेस पता चल जाती है तो
बहुत इजी होता है। मैक एड्रेस चेंजर बहुत
सारे टूल्स आते हैं। काली में मैक चेंजर
का यूटिलिटी बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट है। मैक चेंजर
यूटिलिटी यूज़ किया जाता है। Windows में
मैक चेंजर करके एक टूल आता है। उसको आप
यूज़ कर सकते हैं। मैक एड्रेस को टेंपरेरी
चेंज करके। अगर आप उस मैक एड्रेस से अपना
मैक एड्रेस चेंज कर देते हैं जो उस
नेटवर्क के अंदर एक ऑलरेडी डिवाइस
कनेक्टेड है तो पॉसिबबली हो सकता है कि
आपका डिवाइस उस नेटवर्क से भी कनेक्ट हो
जाए क्योंकि वो अलाउड है उस राउटर के मैक
फिल्टरिंग लिस्ट में तो दिस दिस हैपेंस
यूजुअली हैपेंस राइट
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
क्या बात है आई थिंक यू गॉट इट सो आई थिंक
आप सबको आज की सेशन यह आज की सेशन यहां पे
समाप्त होती आई होप कि आपको समझ में आ गई
होगी। एक रिक्वेस्ट मैं आप सब से करूंगा।
अगेन अगेन मैं आपको बोल रहा हूं। आई होप
कि आप इस बार इस चीज को सिंसियरली लेंगे।
250 से 200 से लेके 100 कमेंट कर दिए हैं
मैंने। जेन्युइन और यूनिक एक ही बंदे 10
कमेंट करके कोई फायदा नहीं है। जेन्युइन
कीजिए कमेंट। यूनिक कमेंट्स कीजिए। लोगों
के बीच शेयर कीजिए इन क्लासेस को। उनको भी
बताइए इन क्लासेस के बारे में एंड ग्रुप्स
को ज्वाइन कर लीजिए। एंड Lindin पे की
पॉइंट्स को जरूर आप डालिए। और जो जो
टॉपिक्स आपको मेनमेन टॉपिक्स मैं बताता
हूं उन टॉपिक्स को उन मेन टॉपिक्स को आप
Lindin पे की पॉइंट्स के तौर पे लिखिए। जो
टॉपिक्स मैं आपको एक्सप्लोर करने के लिए
बोलता हूं उसको खुद से भी एक्सप्लोर
कीजिए। थोड़ा पढ़िए उसके बारे में। बहुत
डीप नहीं जाना है। बेसिक्स जानकारी लीजिए।
उनके भी की पॉइंट्स को Lindin पे डालिए।
हमें टैग कीजिए डेफ्रोनिक्स को। एंड इस
तरीके से आपकी नोट्स भी प्रिपेयर होंगी।
की पॉइंट्स भी बनेंगे। नोट्स जरूर बनाइए।
हमारे नोट्स पे डिपेंड मत रहिए। मैं आपको
बार-बार बोल रहा हूं। मत रहिए डिपेंड।
नोट्स जरूर बनाइए खुद के। एंड जितनी
ज्यादा रिवाइज कर सके कीजिए। जब आप एक
लाइव अटेंड कर लेते हैं उसके बाद एक बार
और रिकॉर्डिंग को आप देखिए। क्योंकि अगर
आप रिकॉर्डिंग देख रहे हैं लाइव देखने के
बाद तो आपकी जो वो नॉलेज जो स्टिक होनी
चाहिए माइंड में वो स्टिक हो जाएगी। वो
परमानेंट आपके साथ हो जाएगी। आप एक ही चीज
को जब दो बार देखते हैं ना दो बार तो वो
आपके साथ ज्यादा टाइम तक आपसे कनेक्ट हो
जाता है और आपके दिमाग में बैठ जाता है।
मेमोराइज हो जाता है। राइट? दैट्स इट।
चलिए टॉप फैंस की एक बार लिस्ट चेक आउट कर
लेते हैं।
ओके। सो टॉप फैंस में यहां पर लिस्ट है
यहां पे। मैं नाम सबके नहीं ले सकता हूं
क्योंकि 50 लोग होते हैं तो बहुत टाइम
जाता है। बट यहां पे मैं आपको दिखा देता
हूं। टॉप फैंस के लिस्ट में यह सारे लोग
हैं यहां पे फोर स्कल से लेके। एंड यहां
पे यह सारे लोग हैं टॉप फैंस के लिस्ट
में। आप देख सकते हैं आप सभी लोग। एंड दीज़
पीपल आर द रीज़न। बेसिकली इनके अलावा जितने
भी लोग यहां पर देख रहे हैं यह 50 लोग साथ
में जो बाकी लोग हैं एंड वी आर गोइंग विद
दिस पर्टिकुलर सेशंस एंड ऑल। सो अच्छा
लगता है आप लोग यहां सेशन के साथ आते हैं
जुड़ते हैं। ऑल दी स्टॉप फैंस लिस्ट एंड
आई होप कि आप कुछ अच्छा सीख के जाते हैं
इन सेशन से। कुछ स्किल लेकर जाते हैं, गेन
करते हैं आप एंड आपके लिए बेनिफिशियल होता
है। सो दैट्स ऑल फॉर दिस सेशन गाइस। अ आई
होप कि आपको मजा आया होगा। चीजें सीखने को
नई मिली होंगी। नई-नई टॉपिक्स, नई-नई
कांसेप्ट्स आपको समझ में आए होंगे। जो
कांसेप्ट नहीं समझ में आए वापस से रिवाइज
कीजिएगा। वीडियो वापस से रिकॉर्डिंग
देखिएगा। कुछ टॉपिक्स को खुद से एक्सप्लोर
भी कीजिएगा। आपको और ज्यादा मजा आएगा। ठीक
है? दैट्स इट।
ओके। ज्ञानश
आई [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] विल
ट्राई।
ओके। दैट्स ऑल फॉर टुडे सेशन गाइस।
कमेंट्स कर लीजिएगा अपना एंड जल्दी ही हम
नेक्स्ट सेशन लेकर आएंगे। थैंक यू सो मच
एंड शुभ रात्रि। नमस्ते। टाटा बाय-ब गुड
नाइट।
या वेलकम वेलकम वेलकम
वेरी वेलकम गाइस। थैंक यू। थैंक यू टाटा।